foreign
take their seats we're going to get
started and I'm going to start um
uh representative smart would you lead
us in the Pledge of Allegiance please
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
foreign
thank you very much everybody and
welcome to environment and agriculture
we have
Bill hearing this morning
or hb253
establishing a committee to ex to study
extended producer responsibility
I'm going to open that hearing and have
representative dutse introduce this bill
to us thank you good morning good
morning thank you madam chair and
committee members I am going to be
reading a testimony by the prime sponsor
representative parshall and can take
questions after that
uh
as stated in previous testimony the full
cost of product packaging does not show
up at the time of purchase
rather it appears on my Municipal tax
bill
this cost of disposal is shifted
entirely from the producer to the
consumer and has real costs in terms of
both economics and the environment this
is why an examination of extended
producer responsibility will be of
benefit to our state a common model that
is in use elsewhere would be to contract
with an established packaging material
stewardship organization
the stewardship program will collect
certain waste stream costs from
participating municipalities in
connection with packaging producers
questions for a study committee may
include whether payments from producers
of packaging material will be based on
the amount of weight of packaging
material or some other metric other
questions could be in how to
differentiate various materials whether
they be electronic paper plastic or
other categories within our waste stream
would producer payments received by the
stewardship organization be used solely
to reimburse participating
municipalities or could the stewardship
organization use a reasonable portion of
producer payments to cover operational
expenses and to provide for education
and infrastructure aimed at reducing
packaging waste a study committee could
also ask if producers May offset some
portion of this payment obligation by
meeting other program incentives
obviously there are many issues to work
through before a comprehensive and
workable piece of legislation can be
drafted this makes the work of a study
committee imperative along with calling
Witnesses and receiving testimony the
committee would focus all of his efforts
into drafting legislation within good
input from numerous stakeholders
as consumers of these products we have
little to say on how they are delivered
to us there are hidden costs that we
absorb both in our Municipal budgets and
our environment this is our opportunity
to place the burden of packaging
decisions
squarely where it belongs thank you
thank you representative dutsy so I have
a question with and I know that you're
just introducing this for representative
partial
but the bill itself doesn't is not
um explicitly
make the questions that you posed in his
introduction
in this bill
it's
it just says that the committee shall
study shall examine waste reduction
goals
um
through extended you know in their
examining the waste reduction goals
established in RSA 149
M with emphasis on the Improvement of
Municipal recycling reducing solid waste
flow and reducing taxpayer costs in
support of Municipal transfer stations
through extended producer responsibility
but it doesn't actually direct the
committee to look at the particular
questions that you posed in the
introduction do you think the bill
should be amended to include those
I don't think so because if you look at
the the very first line there is
established a committee to study
extended producer responsibility in
order to provide relief to the cost of
municipalities and solid waste disposal
and I believe what representative
Parcell is trying to bring up in his
testimony is that there are
extender producer responsibility is a
broad topic there's a lot of different
things in play and I think in his
testimony he's suggesting that these are
some of the things that the committee
could look at and that's the reason why
we need a committee I will give you an
example
I'm working with a group of people now
uh trying to craft a container deposit
system known as a bottle bill
and in a number of in a number of states
and a number of organizations considers
a bottle Bill to be a foundational
legislation for extended producer
responsibility so that's usually the
start of
moving forward in this area and I can
tell you it has I call it an octopus
with a thousand arms because there are
so many things to consider
in this kind of legislation you know
that that you need
a lot of research and a lot of time to
look at it and I think what this bill
does in this whole area is begin the
process to bring the stakeholders
involved so that we can at least
understand
how we might
craft legislation for epr that works for
New Hampshire because what I have seen
in working on the bottle bill is that
you just can't take a piece of
legislation from another state and think
it's going to work here
were unique and I think and I think that
opening statement is Broad enough to
bring in all of these ideas I think the
committee would have to then sit through
them
because my concern is that if we make
this study committee
too broad they really you know that we
have time constraints and so forth but
if it's made too broad you know just
study extended producer responsibility
that's such a huge topic I don't know
how they could distill anything down
to be of meaning there's just so much
that they could be looking at and I
think it from from my perspective I
think it just makes more sense to kind
of maybe restrict to to look at specific
parts of epr
well I I think if correct me if I'm
wrong but I think we have two states
right now that have epr legislation in
place I think one is Oregon one is Maine
and I would assume that that's where
they would probably
want to start looking at those existing
laws how they were implemented where
they're going and then go from there but
that's just a guess okay a question from
representative Murray thank you madam
chair
um
and thank you for taking my question so
are you aware that a similar version of
this came before that we were able to
kind of have a subcommittee work group
on and uh looked at this concept of epr
that was the bill for electronics epr
Electronics or was there a committee
um there was it was referred to in a
room study if I remember correctly in
the previous biennium
nope okay I'd have to say I'm not I
don't remember that one no that's okay
in which case I was going to ask um if
you were aware of several of the
findings that came out of that of which
I had chaired that subcommittee work
session
representative Murray so you're saying
that you chaired the EP I thought it was
the epr for electronics was that it and
and okay
so there's a so there's a preview
there's a previous epr committee there
was a study that was done
last year we had a bill
requested the study committee on elect
on epr we
um we voted it was in the second year we
voted it uh interim study and we were
expecting to uh and we also put it into
a sort of an Omnibus study bill uh 1049
that was going to study a whole lot of
stuff but the Senate killed that
and that study is available and then
there was we did the interim study and
Megan chaired that interim study session
I'm sorry say that again thank you that
for that representative Bixby
[Laughter]
you have a follow-up
you have a follow-up yeah thank you
madam chair
um thank you so
to your point uh Madam chair about
whether or not epr should
um be the focus I think we had had
looked at the fact that there were if
memory serves correctly 13 states at
that point mulling over various aspects
of the legislation for extended producer
responsibility Maine is leading in that
area and they have established a program
already and part of the I think the
findings and the discussion were that
um
it's not a one-size-fits-all model
depending on how things are proceeding
through States and that's why we said
that yes this was worthy of we felt as a
subcommittee work session that it was
worthy of future legislation and I think
that that is representative partials
attempt to do to do that to bring a
study committee that looks at what the
right fit would be for New Hampshire is
that correct
I'm not privy to representative
powershell's thinking you know on the
bill
um I'm a co-sponsor on it because I
support it and I I agree with you
completely it's not
um a couple of years ago I looked into a
possible epr regarding tires okay
because there was there was an issue
there is an issue in the Connecticut
River of tires being thrown in and and
so thinking about how we could go ahead
and look um track you know
um the the various ways that that tires
can go through a system and we could
um recycle them or
dispose of them correctly and again it's
a it's a very complicated issue and I
think I I agree with you we need a study
to at least start it and look at what
works for New Hampshire
um and it's it's you know
um
we might not get anything definitive out
of this committee like we would want but
it's a start and I think from there we
can figure out
um where we might want to go and
representative Dusty now I just became I
was just appointed to be the house
member on the solid waste working group
is that something that they are not
already studying are they are they
looking at epr
at all
not I don't know not that I'm aware of I
mean I've attended some of their
sessions
um via zoom and you know I think
um you know they're looking at the whole
uh landfill issue obviously this is a
part of it
um measuring you know uh measuring our
waste being able to track whether or not
we're meeting some of our goals
um I'm not sure maybe other people on
the committee know but I don't think
that they've drilled down that far
because they've had other issues that
they've had to deal with uh rep Madam
chairman one of the things that I get
from what you know being involved in
this for the last couple of years is
that the state of New Hampshire is so
far behind in this area we haven't met
our goals and correct me if I'm wrong I
believe from the early 90s it may even
go back to the 80s
other states are moving ahead of us
we've got a lot of issues going on where
the state of Massachusetts for example
and other states are Banning the
disposal of materials which means that
those materials are more likely to end
up in New Hampshire and at even if this
bill may not be perfect I think having a
committee look at it and working with
the Solid Waste Management Group I don't
think we can put too many hands on deck
right now for the whole issue of
waste and waste reduction
thank you yeah representative Howard
thank you madam chair
um I I agree with you that um the the
seems like the outcomes or the the
report from the this because the the
topic is so broad it seems like the
report could be could come back yes
they're they're just finding that there
is an an extended responsibility
and I I would um
suggest that we make it more that we
report more specific about not just
about the extended responsibility but
also the pro the materials and products
for which that we for which they are
responsible and that we could use to
reduce the
um the waist chain
representative Murray uh thank you madam
chair
um to that I would happily um if if it
is the will of the body to narrow the
focus down I'm happy to contribute my
notes from the last
um sort of iteration of things that
discuss the varying types of epr
programs that are out there and what
that looks like so if that's something
I'm happy to contribute that
sure I'm I can I think we can also have
our committee researcher do some
checking around on some things having to
do with epr and who is what states have
instituted epr and and what means and
fashion they've done that representative
Bixby you have a question yes so um
uh I have a very short question which
you probably will say that will depend
on the committee but uh it's currently
written uh to uh have
um
two members of the Senate uh as three
house members my experience in study
committees has been it's hard enough to
get one member of the Senate to show up
uh so would uh do you believe that this
Prime sponsor would be amenable to
amending it to have one member
of the Senate
I can't speak for representative partial
but I I would assume that he would be
agreeable to that uh if it you know if
it allows us to get this bill uh passed
follow up follow up go ahead so um
there seems to be some concern that uh
the
um as as written is not sufficiently
directive in terms of what to be studied
what should be studied uh but would you
uh think that it would make sense to uh
use this study committee in order to
identify those aspects of epr that are
most amenable to uh being worked on in
New Hampshire sooner rather than later
and uh and perhaps
um amending it to uh to indicate that
that we're looking at looking to find
the best Avenues
uh absolutely representative Bixby I
mean I think one of the benefits that we
have right now is that I believe you
have 10 states that have bottle bills in
place I know Michigan goes back to 1978
so we can look at the success rate there
you've indicated that there's 13 other
states you know that are looking at epr
legislation and
um you know this gives us an opportunity
to see what what they have focused on
um as maybe the the best place to start
it's such a huge area that I think you
know we we just need to to look at what
would be the most appropriate for New
Hampshire where we need to start and
then go from there but I I totally agree
with you
representative Murray uh Madam chair I I
also just wanted to make sure that we
noted that um also
um representative Ebel is a co-sponsor
on this piece of legislation yes and so
um I know that she does a lot of work
with solid waste working group as well
so
um she's the chair correct so
um to that end I I
think that this should be something that
we move to take a look at in a way that
um maybe gives the most flexibility as
possible to get as many of the ideas
compiled okay
any other questions for uh
representative datsey
and I believe the sponsor would be very
agreeable to you know any additions or
changes to the bill to make it the best
bill that we possibly can okay thank you
I don't have any other pink cards for
this uh for this bill is there anybody
else who wishes to
make comments or or testify in favor or
against representative Bixby uh one yes
ma'am
okay well
just fill out a pink card and then have
a seat you can testify first and hand
that in after that'd be fine
we might also be able to get information
from Mr North about the status of epr
and it's always working group from whom
Mr Nork oh Mr Nork yes as well hello
your microphone please and and welcome
to environment there's a button on the
bottom yeah there you go I'm in a red
now and state your name state your name
where you're from thank you my name is
Cynthia Walter I'm from Dover and um
just driving a lot driving here took me
longer than I expected so I'm late I'm
sorry
um I saw trash all along the highway
um I had to stop and get just just the
other day we Dover has run out of bags
for its Municipal recycling uh uh ZIP
program because we have so much waste
everybody's using up the bags
um these bags are very expensive so
people with low income have a serious
problem with uh affording those bags
you know and I also am a scientist who
studies pollution
and people's exposures to toxics and
packaging is of course a major source of
all of that so we have problems from
from the traffic in every direction from
packaging and the extended producer
responsibility bills that we've seen in
all those states that you've just
mentioned are different ways of
approaching this massive complicated
problem and I think this study committee
is the way to engage the stakeholders
it's also a way to help many of us small
many of the small business people that
are just the Hallmark and the ground
ground strength of New Hampshire
they need ways to safely package their
products to their customers and those
packaging materials we've been a few of
us in a group have been meeting with
some of the packaging suppliers
and there's just not the options that
those small business people need in this
region so the extended producer
responsibility in plan can involve then
ways to enhance our small businesses and
help them get the packaging that's safe
and and responsible and so forth so I
think there's just many many
stakeholders that could benefit from
this work and I please hope that you
pass it and move it as fast as we can
thank you thank you for your comments
anyone you have questions representative
Murray thank you madam chair for taking
my question um to your point
um and thank you for taking my question
um are you aware of organizations that
are all that are working towards this
very goal such as the Ellen MacArthur
Foundation who has an international
effort of signatories of
of uh various stakeholders including
manufacturers who are signing on who are
small medium and large corporations
um who are in agreement that
there needs to be some effort to make
sure that there is a closed cycle and
the ability to have
um items recovered
well that particular one I'm sorry I'm
poor hearing but maybe you can spell it
out for me at some point after the
meeting sure is to I don't want to delay
you though but I'd be happy to hear
about that group but I'll need it on
writing
that ears thank you no problem thank you
anybody else with questions
thank you very much for taking the time
to come up here and testify
and I would also like to Now call
Michael Nork from nhdes to come and
good morning
good morning Madam chair members of the
committee
um my name is Michael Nork I'm with the
New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services Solid Waste
Management Bureau I wasn't actually
intending to speak but I'm happy to
answer any questions for the committee I
just I also want to mention that the
department does support this we have no
reason to not want to investigate this
issue it's something we're aware of
other states are obviously looking
into and developing their own policies
so
um you know it's something that has been
in place for a number of years in Canada
and a number of states in the Northeast
and on the west coast as well so
um you know it is something that comes
up a lot and um
I am aware that the solid waste working
group
could be generally interpret the charge
of that group could be generally
interpreted interpreted to uh
You Know cover things topics like epr uh
but the charge of that group is so broad
that I think representative evil has
expressed to me that it couldn't hurt to
have another group uh you know dive a
little bit deeper into this and maybe
coordinate with the solid waste working
group on this kind of topic so we see no
harm in in looking into the issue it's
obviously a very complicated issue
and the devils are always in the details
in terms of how you implement them
um and how you know that's what defines
how they're how they're how effective
they can be but it's something I think
we we the department would support
so with that happy to take any questions
thank you with that I have a question is
from a department standpoint do you see
any one or two or three particular
products that cause a great deal of
problem or issue with our you know with
disposal in New Hampshire
that's a great question I think we
haven't had a lot of time to sit back
and and look at that internally as
within our own day-to-day
um
I I serve on the board of the Northeast
Recycling Council
um
and through my work with that group I am
aware of what other states have
implemented in terms of epr programs and
where they started a lot of them started
with electronics recycling due to the
nature of
uh you know how they're those those
types of material like Electronics
products tends to have tend to have uh
a lot of precious metals and sometimes
hazardous materials that should be
recovered and not not sent to the solid
waste stream so that's where a lot of
States I think initially started they
also started with things like paint
which is also something that tends to to
cross over into the world of hazardous
waste
um so looking at things from a toxicity
standpoint that's that's where some
states have started there's also
concerns about
uh you know more recently especially in
Maine
um you know the cost of managing these
materials and not just the toxicity
um you know not just a concern about
toxicity but also how much of these
things we're generating and how much of
it ends up in our landfills or
incinerators so they're looking at
things like packaging more generally
that that is a very complex topic
um so epr can be taken in any number of
directions
um
but in terms of from what I'm familiar
with at least States seem to have taken
a more uh at least initial steps around
toxicity and identifying those items
that are pose more of a risk from that
standpoint
is it your in your opinion
that a study committee would be more
successful if they if if it weren't as
broad if maybe we just looked at
um
a dozen things or you know half a dozen
things
that we might want to focus in on in
terms of epr
I I think that that could help uh with
narrowing the focus a little bit could
potentially make it a more
productive uh conversation and focus the
the direction of the group a little bit
more
um I hadn't really given consideration
to how that might be done but that that
is possibly uh uh that could be a
beneficial Amendment to the Bill thank
you
representative Murray thank you madam
chair um thank you for taking my
question
um to your point about uh packaging and
the complexities if memory serves me
correct I think you also were there way
back when in hb617 when we discussed
multi-layer packaging and the various
complexities around it as well as
um many many of those other types of
packaging which are not necessarily
recoverable in a way and they ultimately
end up landfilled
um so to that end uh I I am wondering
whether or not
I I guess I will push back a little bit
on whether or not narrowing the scope
would potentially eliminate looking at
things that we should really
focus on and so I'm just curious as to
how how we Define that scope if if
you're looking for an amendment
yeah thank you for the question to be
clear I'm not advocating for an
amendment I would just uh opining that
potentially that could help in terms of
I know with study committees they often
don't have a lot of time uh to really
focus on the issue uh at hand because of
deadlines and you know reporting
deadlines and whatnot
um so I'm just thinking that it could
potentially be beneficial to to identify
priorities or topics or even material
types or product types
um but I I see where you're coming from
representative Murray that that there is
such a broad potential application for
epr that
you know I just don't know what the best
the best methodology is to tackle it
because it is such a broad complex topic
um so I'm not I'm fear I'm not being
very helpful but that's it's the nature
of the Beast I think
representative germana thank you very
much Madam chair I was also wondering
about packaging and I was thinking about
there are a couple of places I'm from
Keene and in Keene we have a couple of
places now that uh when you get coffee
you know the entire the the Cup itself
uh and the you know the the thing that
keeps your hand from getting too hot
forget what that's called uh and the lid
are all compostable right I assume that
the lid is maybe cornstarch based or
something like that and the same would
be true you know if you bought a cup of
soup or something like that so I was
wondering if there is any effort uh on
the part of the department and part of
the state to kind of uh particularly
with that kind of packaging to move us
further in the direction of that kind of
packaging right as opposed to I mean how
many you stop into Cumberland Farms or
any other place you can still get
styrofoam cups for your coffee right and
other uh containers that really just
fill our landfill when clearly there is
the technology that allows us to produce
containers that are compostable so I'm
wondering number one if that might fall
into the purview of this kind of study
and if anything is currently in the
works to help us move in the direction
of that kind of Packaging
that's a great question
um
in terms of what currently might be
happening uh the department has issued a
solid waste management plan uh back in
late 2022 it identifies a number of
strategies and actions some of it
could could apply to the kind of
situation you're talking about where
reducing use of certain types of
packaging or reducing single-use
packaging or in
trying to encourage more recycling or
recyclability of Inc of that type of
Packaging
um one of the challenges is that we
don't necessarily have
a way to make that happen for sure but
we can encourage we can educate we can
provide information so that's that's one
of the challenges with moving the needle
so to speak on these kinds of social
behavioral issues
I think that's where epr the intention
of epr is to
create a framework that kind of requires
manufacturers and product Brands to
adhere to some sort of code or some sort
of standard
for their products
if the onus is on the manufacturer or
the brand for end of life management
as a profit driven
business they are probably going to opt
for materials and packaging that are
less expensive to manage at the end of
life so to your point you know
compostable packaging or things that can
go to higher and better use that
potentially could be recycled and have
some sort of market value
as a commodity are going to be something
that they would probably be more willing
to kind of direct their efforts to
rather than
if they don't have to think about what
the the end of life management of their
packaging is then they're just going to
continue business as usual status quo so
so I think that's where APR comes in is
it really tries to
create some sort of economic incentive
essentially because at the end of the
day the business is going to be
the one that foots the build you know so
they're going to look to minimize costs
wherever they can I hope that answers
your question yes can I follow up Madam
chair sure follow up uh and like
speaking of that kind of incentive right
which it makes sense right so even if
there were some costs that is that is
passed on to the consumer for example
when you buy your your cup of coffee I
bought my cup of coffee in the morning
uh it seems to me that there would be an
offset potentially as we're dealing with
uh diminishing landfill space and and
increasing prices for landfills right
because we have to now truck waste
greater distances because we're running
out of landfill space it seems that
perhaps for consumers uh there would be
an offset even if there's a small you
know increase in what you're paying for
that cup of coffee uh because of of the
packaging that it would be offset
potentially by savings or keeping our
landfill costs from continuing to
increase
I I think that's a fair assessment thank
you thank you madam chair
representative Dusty I can't take your
questions because you introduced the
bill so I'm sorry for that
representative Murray uh thank you madam
chair I think this discussion that we're
having before us if I may illustrates
how complex the issue really is and how
many different products epr really
touches
and uh to that end uh
I think that it is
um something I'm curious about
what your vision for the study
committee's communication with the solid
waste working group does that directive
need to be in the bill
to that end you were saying potentially
there was hope that the two could
communicate with one another
um I just wanted to make sure if that
the named members were working on that
that they have the ability to
communicate with you directly or how how
would that work for swag I guess is what
I'm wondering
a good question
I don't know that I have the answer
um
I I I just think that if because the the
topics could overlap between the two
groups there may
it may be beneficial to have some
coordination but I don't know if that
needs to be formalized I would leave
that to the committee to to think about
in terms of you know how to craft the
policy if they decide to go forward
thank you madam chair may it wasn't a
question I wanted to answer
representative germanna is that allowed
or not if not that's fine
uh no I don't believe so because we are
we are listening to testimony okay yeah
representative so that uh discussion
between committee members is something
that
um is typically done in uh study uh
study session uh subsequent to the
hearing because the hearing gives
priority to people who are testifying
thank you for that clarification
any other questions for Mr nork
anybody no thank you I appreciate you
coming and testifying thank you and now
I'd like to call
um Mr John Tuthill from my town of
Acworth welcome to environment
agriculture
uh thank you madam chairman members of
the committee my name is John Tuthill
from Acworth in Sullivan County
um a quarter of a century ago I was
sitting on this committee and we were
talking about epr and these Concepts
at that time so I'm very pleased that
this bill is coming forward and I
strongly support it uh
I suppose this gratuitous to say that
it's long overdue but it certainly is
time for us to be discussing this
um Michael Nork from Des essentially
covered what I think is is really the
critical issue which is focusing on
toxicity
a lot of our difficulties with Solid
Waste Management
have to do with the fact there actually
is a great deal of toxic material in the
way streams we're using waste streams
the way we used to use Rivers before the
Clean Water Act started
putting some controls on that you have a
great flow of material passing through
and we have a small segment of
of waste materials that really are quite
hazardous but by diluting them in a much
greater stream of
of papers and cardboard and just general
household refuse
um
it's possible to
send these materials off into the world
where they are treated to some extent or
controlled at landfills or incinerators
or wastewater treatment plants but
nonetheless
in the end a lot of this talks and
material is getting back out into the
environment into our
agricultural lands and into Food
Supplies so I think that's where epr can
really make a difference in terms of
protecting the environment and
improving public health or reducing risk
to Public Health perhaps would be a
better way of putting that I'll leave it
at that I said I would speak for one
minute I just really wanted to see I
strongly support this this initiative
and I'm very pleased it's happening
having lived in Europe at the time that
uh
epr was coming into effect through the
European Union you saw a dramatic change
in packaging and a reduction in the
amount of materials that were being used
in packaging consumer goods thank you
appreciate it representative Murray uh
thank you madam chair for taking my
question and thank you for taking my
question
um when you're talking about toxicity
and packaging can you elaborate a little
bit more about how the two interrelate
are there are there
things added to packaging that make them
not only more complex but also more
toxic uh yes
um and a quarter of a century ago this
was perhaps more of a problem because
actually industry manufacturers have
adapted and to some extent there have
been laws at the federal and and I think
to some extent at the state level the UF
stabilizers in Plastics you have
colorants what makes those detergent
bottles almost jump off the shelf into
your cart is in a very very bright
colors which often are associated with
heavy metals
the stabilizers themselves can be a
problem in terms of toxicity
we certainly know now about pfas which
is often found in Packaging
that needs to be addressed and I think
that
sending an economic signal through an
epr program would would be useful in
reducing the use of some of these
chemicals in in the recipes for
packaging both in paper and in Plastics
follow-up sure thank you madam chair uh
going back to the comment on uh pfas and
packaging are you referring to non-stick
Coatings in general or what are what are
you what are you uh I mean obviously
pfas is a chain of chemicals and there
are many pfas correct
um are there other non-stick Coatings
that are of concern to you or I'm
certainly not an expert in this field I
mean I've been following
um the story for many many years this is
not something new exactly if you can go
back to Rachel Carson or people like
Theo Colburn back in the 90s we've known
about a lot of these uh problematic
chemicals for a long time that are used
in the Plastics manufacturing industry
and and were used more at one time in
the paper industry
um
but no I I actually can't uh discourse
in depth on on the actual particulars of
of these chemicals there certainly are
experts who can do that and hopefully
the study committee would actually Avail
themselves of some of that expertise
any other questions for Mr Tuthill
seeing none thank you so much for coming
and joining us this morning
thank you uh I I would like to ask the
committee I see that the sponsor of the
bill has joined us does anybody from the
committee actually have a question for
the bill sponsor yes
representative partial would you please
take the seat I would love to
and I'll make sure shortly thank you
so go ahead representative Bixby you had
a question
I asked a couple of questions of
Representative dutzie which uh through
which the answer was she couldn't read
your mind but she kind of guessed that
you what your response might be so I'm
gonna just play put them to you uh in
terms of potentially amending the bill
uh one issue uh is simply the matter of
uh reducing the number of Senators to
one so we'll have at least one who might
show up uh and the other question is uh
do you think it might make sense to
um
uh in the committee charge make uh
provide a a list of potential areas to
look at to clarify because this is a
huge topic to clarify some priorities
thank you for the question and uh
welcome I'd like to say thank you
committee for allowing me to justify
um
I my only concern with uh
with one Senator and three
Representatives is that it opens the
door for uh Thai votes but I am more
than open to it if that's the will of
this uh Ena committee I would be more
than happy to offer such an amendment
um as far as out there is uh there are a
number of concerns about EPA legislation
what IT addresses we for Testimony this
morning about the difference between
addressing electronic technology and the
disposal of our plastic bottles I think
that both are very valid points to look
at where you have one committee to study
all of them it makes sense and again I'd
be more than happy to have include areas
of potential outline like I think was
given to my testimony it's written
testimony addressing these various
concerns yes
thank you I'm sorry
um any other questions for
representative partial
seeing none
um you have my uh something else to add
what more thought if I may
um
and that is uh
this bill is for a study group because I
really do feel that the issues posed by
this are quite large but I think at the
end of the day the focus of this is
something that we all not only
decreasing our waste flow of something
well in favor of but also giving some
relief to the municipal taxpayers who
are paying the Tipping fees in these
towns I think that's also vital to
address it as part of this bill
thank you and so it
as a follow-up to what representative
Bixby had said about
um perhaps restricting or or having the
scope of the study be more specific
perhaps um would you think it be a good
idea for the study committee to decide
whether or not they would want to
restrict
a study of you know just certain items
or
so that they are not you know having to
deal with such a broad issue that
perhaps they can determine what the
priorities would be for what they're
going to study
well I'd be happy to furnish a hopefully
comprehensive list of areas be examined
I would not presume on the study
committee on what they wish to on the
areas they wish to focus on I think that
sounds perfectly reasonable thank you
representative NAB
much Madam chair thank you for taking my
question
um you have a comment in here about
soliciting
committee deems relevant who do you
think about oh sorry who do you think
about when you talk about that because
it seems like that might help also
Define the goals as to who you solicit
information from
uh what do I want to say people like
outside of Des who are other
organizations that you would want to
speak to
there are a number of uh
waste groups around the state the New
Hampshire Network for one in ten towns
initiative uh I think they may also may
have some worthy testimony uh I would
also think perhaps our Municipal
Association may have some worthwhile
input when it comes to how we're
currently managing our waste flow and
um as far as
improvements in that area
um there's two that let's come off the
top of my mind
representative Murray
thank you madam chair uh to that end uh
I guess would you
would you believe that's okay yeah thank
you
um that there are a large range of
stakeholders who would come and testify
on those as I have experienced through
hb617 everybody from retailers
manufacturers to hospital associations
the list is quite broad would you not
agree I would agree and I think maybe
one of the tasks of the study could be
might have is trying to avoid redundancy
of testimony because of that factor I'd
like to see your time sweat wisely thank
you
representative Howard
thank you madam chair and thanks for
taking the question um I sort of asked
this of Representative Desi earlier
um and maybe I can phrase it a little
bit better this time given the broad you
know sort of um Mandate of the bill
um how how would you define the the
report outcomes like what what are the
specific goals that you that you would
want the report to address
I would be happy
if we could come to a consensus on
legislation to move the whole concept of
EPA epr forward in the state I that is
the goal of this study group I believe
follow-up sure
um so and I said earlier that that it
could be that the report basically
establishes that there is an epr and is
do you anticipate or that there is an
existence of APR do you anticipate that
it would name
materials or or
um
specific companies or or
producers
I would again hate Brazil man what the
studies what findings of the committee
may make
um
but I think that at the minimum if you
identify a stewardship organization to
manage the waste flow and some
guidelines and how for collection I
think that at a minimum would be perhaps
a wise area for the committee to look at
or
yes
representative germana thank you madam
chair and thank you representative
partial uh and in connection with
representative Howard's question I see
uh you're one of the provisions of of
the bill would be uh suggested
legislation in order to help
RSA 149 am in order to better meet the
waste reduction goals therein so I
assume one of the uh possible outcomes
of such a committee would be to perhaps
suggest some pieces of legislation maybe
that's taking legislation that has been
enacted in Maine or other states and and
and and then crafting it in a way that
that suits the interests of New
Hampshire so I assume that uh potential
legislation uh would also be a product
of the committee's work
I think that's an implicit in the uh
um in the in the bill
um yes
thank you thank you madam chair
any other questions
seeing none I want to thank you for
testifying is there anybody else I don't
have any more pink cards is there
anybody else who wishes to speak on
house bill
253.
seeing none I will then close this
hearing I also want to report that we
had on our blue sheet we had six people
in favor of this bill and on the online
portal we had 62 people in favor of this
bill three people against and one person
signed in as neutral
so I will pass that along
yes yeah did you get that 62 in favor
three opposed and one neutral
so with that this hearing is closed
um do we have your written testimony
representative partial
or I could submit it electronically if
you prefer
I'm a paperless person whatever you
would like
thank you
okay I am going to
um
I guess we're going to adjourn our
committee I thought we would have more
people speaking in favor or against this
bill this uh this morning but uh our
next hearing is at one o'clock uh for HB
56 relative to permits for the sighting
of new landfills
and so we will be taking off that time
until then representative Bixby yeah I'd
just like to uh recommend that uh we
probably should uh spend some time in a
work session on this in order to
um just clarify any any possible
necessary amendments does that I had
planned to do that next week great in
the morning good thank you so I don't
know if there would be any
um
notion of bringing uh an amendment
before then
I don't know
I think that might be a possibility
um
we can talk with a prime sponsor and see
what he'd be amenable with and see if we
can
get some rough draft or something put
together so we have something to discuss
okay wonderful
So the plan is for next week uh in the
morning I wanted to have a work session
on this bill as well as that I'm
assuming we're going to have some
discussions on the landfill sighting
bills
um to have a work session in the morning
for these three bills there's also
another bill
um
it's a HB 221 and I think that there was
that that's the land acquisition bill
for the land trust and I think that you
were working on an amendment for that
yeah I'll be preparing an amendment for
that okay so those four bills we can
talk about uh in a work session next
week
in the morning and in the afternoon
we'll have an exact session and I'm not
sure
if we want to include these three bills
that we're going to hear today in the
exact session next week
I don't think we can just get the
landfill can you put your um microphone
in I don't think that we can figure out
what needs to happen with the landfill
Bill uh out sufficiently to be able to
um
exec on uh on next tomorrow afternoon
yeah sure thank you madam chair I I just
don't know what we're going to hear in
the way of testimony today so I I just
want to make sure that we're
I I have no idea what could potentially
come out of that and I don't want to
make any sure
representative kantois
thank you madam chair
um we can always include them but if we
find that we need more time after having
our working group in the morning we can
always postpone them yep
yep
okay
anybody have any other questions or
comments for the good of the committee
seeing none I'd like to adjourn until
one o'clock
thank you
foreign
is pretend to come in this afternoon is
she supposed to
okay I'd like everybody to please take
their seats and get settled we're going
to be getting underway momentarily
foreign
thank you and good afternoon this is uh
and house environment agriculture
committee
and we are going to be hearing bill
number HB 56 relative to permits for the
sighting of new landfills but before we
get underway there's a couple of things
I want to go over
I would appreciate it if people please
mute their phones
um I don't want to have any cell phones
going off in the middle of our hearings
thank you
um
first of all I'd like to have a reminder
of some civility we do not impugn or
ascribe motives to others or you will be
gaveled
so we want to be respectful of
everybody's position on on these two
bills this afternoon
please speak on one bill
um
if you are coming up to speak on HB 56 I
realize that hb602 is very similar you
may speak on both bills at the same time
but if you are coming back up to speak
on hb602 please stay specific to that
bill
and try not to repeat something that's
already been said we've got a lot of
people who want to speak
um and I would like to be respectful of
the time
uh so with that I will start with
um
representative Murray to introduce her
bill HB 56 to our committee
thank you madam chair good afternoon
representative good afternoon to you too
good afternoon committee uh for the
record my name is representative Megan
Murray I represent the towns of Amherst
in Milford I'm here before you uh to
bring forward House Bill 56 which is a
bill that would establish a distance of
a distance to travel requirement for the
uh proposed sighting of landfills and in
that
um what what the bill is asking for is
that any uh applicants seeking to cite a
landfill uses a five-year distance to
travel calculation in a hydrogeological
study that would be at the expense of
the applicant
um putting that forward the bill itself
is the the bill itself is is similar in
nature to uh the bill we saw last year
however I did want to make some mention
that I was aware that
um there were a few things that could
potentially be strengthened and so in
doing so I have prepared an amendment
which you all have which is zero six
zero nine h
and IT addresses a few things with
regard to strengthening some of the
definitions around
what it means
for a pre-existing landfill in
subparagraph C it also mentions uh in
subparagraph C
lines
8 through 10 that we also would like to
see that any perennial bodies of water
traversing a footprint uh be monitored
in accordance with or exceeding U.S EPA
regulations and guidelines it also in
subparagraph D of the original Bill
continues to further elucidate elusive
excuse me elucidate
um The Five-Year distance to travel and
it just says that we would also like
that there's not more than an additional
three years added to the calculated time
of travel
um
and um there are a few other very
scientific explanations which some folks
behind me will speak to better about
in-situ soils and I I am not the person
to speak to the scientific uh nature of
that
and with that I'll happily take any
questions that you may have for me um
like I said
um that the body uh last year the house
felt very strongly that the house take a
position and
um
make sure that we are protecting our
bodies of water and so in doing so we
want to make sure that that happens and
so this is a vehicle that I believe uh
is best suited to do that
thank you representative questions
representative Murray representative
Crichton
thank you madam chair thank you
representative Murray and so this bill
is similar to a bill from last term
the bill from last term was vetoed
by the governor how does this build get
by that beetle
thank you for the question
representative so I do believe that
um I I cannot speak to what is in the
governor's
purview so to to that I will say that we
are taking an additional uh
angle to try and make sure that folks
feel as comfortable as possible to
ensure that
um we are
not trying to
um impinge on any pre-existing landfills
that are in existence and in in doing
that um
I would at least hope that that gives
some additional reinsurance that we
understand that this is a service that
is provided to folks but at the same
time we are also concerned about water
quality
thank you
any other questions
no seeing none thank you very much if
your for your introduction of this bill
[Music]
um
let's see I have uh representative Wendy
Thomas
good afternoon
thank you madam oh thank you sir thank
you madam chair and members of the
committee
I am representative Wendy Thomas I
represent the town of Merrimack and I
come before you today in support of
house bill 56. environmental toxins are
in the news these days recently in an
East Palestine Ohio there was a major
train derailment that has caused nothing
short of a humanitarian crisis
while people in my town of Merrimack
have been systematically poisoned over a
few decades these people have been
poisoned overnight we are seeing photos
of dead fish chickens birds people are
complaining of headaches skin rashes and
difficulty breathing
make no mistake
through no fault of their own because of
this ecological crisis they will lose
their houses lose their town and many
will end up losing their how their
health and even their lives
because of poisonous chemicals that have
been spewed into the environment by
industry
it's very similar to what is happening
in Merrimack however like I said earlier
it's taken us decades to reach a Tipping
Point instead of getting there overnight
but make no mistake we are also losing
our houses our town our health and in
some cases we are losing our lives
our culprit is pfas chemicals released
by an industrial polluter in our town
it's in our water our soil it's in our
air when they incinerate their waste at
night
those of us with contaminated Wells
cannot sell our houses who is going to
buy a house with water that makes you
sick
our pets cats and dogs are dying in
Untold numbers from Cancers and kidney
diseases
they are the true canaries in the coal
mines
pfas chemicals are hormone disruptors
everything in your body is run by
hormones if you question the power of
hormones you have never had a teenage
son
absolutely everything is run by hormones
and when they are disrupted excuse me
chaos ensues
because this has been going on so long
our residents are getting sick we have
high rates of autoimmune disease high
cholesterol diabetes learning
disabilities and alarming rates of
cancer
I have one of those cancers that is
linked to pfas contamination I had my
blood tested and my levels are so high
that my blood is considered toxic I had
to remove parts of my body in an effort
to eliminate a cancer Target before my
cancer could get to it that's right the
price to live in a town that is
contaminated with pfas chemicals is to
amputate parts of our bodies to try to
stay ahead of the anticipated damage
my surgeon after running several genetic
tests has stated that my cancer is most
likely a result of environmental toxins
now I can't say for certain that pfas
gave me cancer but when something is
looking like a duck and quacking like a
duck and when your oncologist after
looking at the research agrees then one
might say with reasonable confidence
that we have a duck here
but think about what that statement
about environmental toxins is really
saying
an industrial polluter most likely gave
me cancer because they couldn't control
what they were releasing
here's the thing about pfas chemicals
you can't taste them you can't smell
them you can't even see them in water
but by the time you discover they are in
the water it's too late these are
forever chemicals that are called
forever because they cannot be destroyed
once they are released into the
environment they are there for good
we have an industrial polluter in our
town but another source of pfas
chemicals is from landfills all of the
pizza boxes Burger wrappers Glide dental
floss and even stain resistant cloth in
landfills contain pfas chemicals
to think that a landfill would not Leach
is to be naive of course they will leech
and to place a landfill within 200 feet
of a body of waters to condemn that
water to Future contamination with not
only pfas but with all of the other
thousands of toxic chemicals that are
found in trash
a CBS article recently stated that
eating a pfas contaminated fish is
equivalent to drinking a month's worth
of pfas contaminated water
once again once it's discovered in the
water it's too late for the environment
and for the people who live there they
will eventually lose their homes their
Community their health and in some cases
their lives now I get it Americans are
consumers we buy things and we throw
away a lot of things until we can get on
top of our consumerism we're going to
need landfills no one is arguing that
but what I'm saying is that we can take
care of our garbage in a reasonable and
safe way and that means not locating
toxic garbage near any body of water
there's plenty of land in New Hampshire
to fill with our trash and it makes me a
little sad to even say that
we must start putting the health and the
welfare of people who live in New
Hampshire first or over corporate greed
Our Lives literally depend upon it I
urge you to support House Bill 56 and to
send it OTP to the house floor thank you
and I'll take any questions thank you
representative Thomas any questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
next I'd like to call Cynthia Walker
uh Walter I'm sorry pardon me I didn't
read it right
Cynthia Walter
yes I'm speaking on my paper copy and my
first remorse will be regarding both
bills but I'd like to also speak to some
of the specifics about 602 a little bit
later this afternoon as well
so I am a um
a retired uh scientist and I'm trying to
find my notes here oh too many too many
documents
um I can just remember what I said
um so I'm a retired biologist and I um
have worked for 35 years on
finding pollution and also finding
solutions to pollution so I have seen
firsthand how leaching of pollutants can
poison Waters forever
I say in my remarks we tracked how
surface activities contaminated ground
Waters and also traveled to in-stream
discharges by we I mean the group of
people that I worked with in
Pennsylvania for over 20 years that
included State energy experts at agency
experts um university civil and
Engineering
civil and environmental Engineers from
universities and so forth
so when we track those surface
activities and saw them impact both
ground Waters and streams we saw also
the drinking water wells were became
unusable streams were missing fish and
the invertebrates they eat and property
values plummeted
um this does not need to happen because
of poor landfill citing I strongly
support both bills because both bills
use well-established principles of
hydrology to cite landfills a major
source as we know of groundwater
pollution
for example both bills use the distance
calculated you just heard of The
Five-Year groundwater travel time from
landfill drainages to sensitive
receptors and I'll speak a little bit
more about those sensitive receptors and
protecting them um in when I talk later
about number 20 602 but to make the
these both come together this approach
has has these benefits predictability
all the stakeholders both the all the
landfill companies current businesses
prospective businesses residents and
Municipal managers can plan their work
to maintain Water Resource protection
when water resources are more
predictable property values are stable
and new businesses are confident to join
the local economy
also under drinking water protection
private wellwaters are better protected
about half of granite Staters rely on
private Wells
Municipal Water managers can plan
treatments for each Municipal Source
without surprises and costly
compensations example my city had to
spend two 27 million dollars to upgrade
water treatment for industrial
groundwater pollutants but that wasn't
enough one area was leaching extremely
serious contaminants and so the company
on their dime had to pay for to install
special treatments meanwhile those took
years to get in place so meanwhile the
city has stopped using that well water
source under those contaminated lands
this forced water restrictions for all
of the city when we had a moderate
drought during the last two years
all this water contamination and
restrictions could have been avoided
please move both bills forward and let's
let the details get worked out with the
expertise of several independent
hydrology experts and then we can toast
to a vigorous safe future for New
Hampshire with a good clean glass of
water thank you thank you Ms Walter any
questions from the committee
seeing none thank you for your testimony
this afternoon
I would like to call Mike wimsat from
New Hampshire Des to come and speak and
testify
good afternoon
oh thank you
I'll continue
good afternoon Madam chair members of
the committee for the record my name is
Mike wimsat I serve as director of the
waste management division for the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services and joining me today I have
assistant Commissioner of our department
Mark Sanborn
uh thank you for the opportunity to
testify regarding House Bill 56 as as
you've heard from the from the bill
sponsor this bill would essentially
require Des to establish the
site-specific setback distance for new
uh post new landfills from any perennial
surface waters and it provides that that
setback distance should be sufficient to
keep any groundwater that's been
contaminated by the landfill from
reaching any nearby surface waters
within a five-year period
and the way that it goes about
establishing that setback distance is to
have an independent hydrogeologist
um do site-specific testing on the site
and determine to in order to estimate
groundwater seepage velocity and then
using the highest seepage velocity
estimated for the site that is used to
determine the five-year setback distance
and
also the bill does provide which I'll
speak to in a moment some for it
provides for the establishment of
project Improvement allowances and each
of those can add basically to offset a
one year of travel time distance for up
to up to up to up to three years
so um
the sponsor did make reference to an
amendment but I have not seen that
Amendment so I won't my testimony will
not address the content of the amendment
DS has several concerns with the bill
um the provisions of the bill as it's
been introduced first it's not clear to
us how the five-year travel time
distance has been established as the
appropriate standard we've expressed you
know even going back to last year some
concern that that may have an impact on
whether any future landfill sites will
be available in the state we just don't
know that at this point so that's a
concern that we have second the
provision that requires the use of the
highest estimated rate
um is is a little unclear to us how that
would be implemented but
based on how we understand
groundwater Hydro geologic testing to
take place on sites it seems possible to
us that an individual measurement could
be made in a particular area of soil on
a site and that using that particular
measurement could result in erroneously
identifying
a a a setback distance that is actually
much greater than would actually need in
other words you might end up making an
estimate of groundwater seepage velocity
that is much faster than the actual
velocity of groundwater traveling to a
particular surface water so we're a
little concerned about how the bill
would instruct the hydrogeologists and
Des to establish that groundwater
seepage velocity and then lastly there's
there's not a lot of detail related to
these
project Improvement allowances and it's
unclear to Des what specific actions or
or improvements are intended by that and
we think that would require further
further
specificity and the other thing I would
say is that we are and everyone knows
that there are a number of bills in play
before the legislature this year
regarding this topic of landfill
setbacks particularly to surface water
the agency is monitoring a bill Senate
Bill 61 which is somewhat similar to
this bill and there's some talk as we
understand it I think I I was President
Ford but I understand maybe an amendment
was approved this morning by the senate
committee which would combine this
Senate Bill 61 with Senate Bill 227
which is a bill that would essentially
instruct Des to hire a consultant or
contractor to do an independent uh
evaluate critical evaluation of setback
requirements in the existing rules and
make recommendations for changes and we
believe that you know both of these
bills could could actually particularly
if they're combined could
provide a good effective strategy for
protecting surface waters and
determining what appropriate landfill
setbacks would be from surface waters
and I'll leave it at that and be happy
to take any questions
uh good afternoon everyone I'll just add
really quickly uh again for the record
Mark Sanborn assistant commissioner New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services
um given this topic and how many bills
there have been and how long this is
going on we've been often asked you know
our positions and as the Director
indicated Des believes the best path
forward is the combined version of SB 61
and SB 227 therefore on the remaining
house and any Senate bills that have
been presented on this uh were not
supportive of moving forward uh in a
different direction other than SB 61
combined with 227 SB 227 and and how
that uh indicates that would have us
move forward so we think that's in the
best interest of the state and in the
best interest of uh dealing with this
issue with that we're happy to take
questions thank you
and I have a question as to
are you aware of any other states that
use this
um
five-year travel distance measurement
thank you madam chair yes I'm aware that
the state of Maine does have some
similar language
um it has some as with any every state
has a different sort of uh structure and
organization to their rules so they
aren't necessarily directly comparable
but I understand that Maine does have a
similar similar Provisions in its rules
and do you know how long they've had
this provision in law for them at all I
don't know specifically I think it's
been in law for quite some time and I
understand that
there are a number of
we have had last year we had some
conversations with our with our
colleagues in Maine and came to
understand that
the the way that they implement the law
I can't say I completely understand it
but it was a little different than what
we were reading in in in this law or in
this bill or in bills that were before
the legislature in discussions with your
with your colleagues in Maine have you
found that they've had any problems
implementing it or haven't had any
problems with it in general
I'm not sure I can answer that I
understand that they do have a provision
for providing variances to various
provisions of the rules and I don't
really understand what the history is on
providing those variances okay thank you
any other questions from the committee
representative germanna thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
and it's uh to piggyback on the
chairwoman's question with regard to
Maine or uh in other states with your
second listed concern about the
possibility of getting uh seepage
velocity measurement in one place which
is inaccurate
um how is it done in other places is
there I I would have assumed but perhaps
out of naivete or ignorance that there
is a procedure that would involve taking
measures in numerous uh places in order
to try to determine an average of
seepage velocity Etc so is there in
Maine or elsewhere a standard way to
attain an accurate measure I apologize I
don't specifically know how Maine
accomplishes that my testimony on this
bill was based on the way we read the
language in this bill and what to put a
little bit more flesh on that concern it
would appear that you it seepage
velocity is something that can be
determined in a relatively small area of
soil
um and there are there are published
methods for for making those estimates
doing doing field measurements and
making those estimates and of course
certainly the geology in New Hampshire
is very variable the formations are very
heterogeneous and the idea that one
individual test in one area of soil
would then be used to determine
the path and the path both the pathway
and the velocity of groundwater over
what could be a very large distance that
sees a lot of soil changes just doesn't
seem it doesn't seem sound to to us as
we look at it
could I may have follow-up sure uh and
and would you with reference to the
Senate bills and the idea of of getting
a hydrogeologist to consult I imagine
this would be one of the things that you
would be looking for that consultant to
provide feedback on sure if you're
referencing Senate Bill 227 yes we think
that uh part of that study should very
likely should include a review of the
neighboring states uh or the Region's
State rules and and a critical
assessment of those to determine what
might be appropriate and applicable for
for use by New Hampshire
thank you thank you madam chair
uh representative Knapp
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question um you referenced the
project Improvement allowances in your
letter for the commissioner does
um and I know you said you didn't have
the amendment in front of you but the
amendment references those including
additional control technology monitoring
programs or funding guarantees that the
department believes may increase the
effective safety of the project so do
you believe Des is capable of evaluating
what those additional improvements might
be and
um changing the travel time or adjusting
it based on that or giving
credits for that I have no doubt that
our staff could could come up with what
they think are appropriate things to
consider when I compare the bill to
Senate Bill 61 for example Senate Bill
61 sets out much more specifically what
those might look like and really the the
nature of the comment in this letter of
testimony is that the language in this
bill is very is very is not very
specific and what we're really
suggesting is much more specificity is
is helpful because obviously when we go
to rule making
um we we do the very best we can to do
an honest assessment and interpretation
of the law but to the extent that the
law is a little more specific it gives
us a lot better Direction
thank you and I just want to add to that
point that's at the heart of the reason
we feel the combined version of 61 and
227 SB 227 is the best approach forward
as the folks are going to be asked to
implement this because it uh it allows
us to work with um we put out an RFP we
would have a hired Consultants who would
have specific tasks to look at we'd have
the research we needed the data we
needed
um before we go into assuming what the
rulemaking should look like we think
that's just a much more effective way of
managing this issue so that we can be
sure what we'd bring forward in rule
making is in the best interest of all
the policies impacting the state of New
Hampshire
representative Bixby
yes uh so um
on under your current permitting
requirements for uh landfills and for
landfill expansions do you require any
Hydro geological assessments of uh
groundwater velocity or seepage velocity
certainly the for any proposed uh
expansion or newly cited landfill there
is a detailed Hydro hydrogeological
study that is required and that would I
don't know if groundwater seepage
velocity I just and I don't know whether
it is specifically listed in the rules
but the rules do require a collection of
a lot of detailed information regarding
hydrogeology and the kinds of
hydrogeologic parameters and
characteristics that would be measured
and evaluated would would lead you to
being able to determine that follow-up
follow-up uh would those procedures
provide a better model for uh the uh for
the measurement than this bill does
um I I'm not sure how to answer that
because the the current rules don't
Envision calculating a travel time
distance
um from the uh the landfill footprint to
a surface water not at least not
specifically so to the extent that a
future Paradigm for these rules includes
calculating a travel time distance they
may there may well be May well need to
be some additional instruction or or
Direction provided for that
follow up follow up yes so uh what is
the purpose of the current uh uh uh
seepage uh assessments that you do
the overall purpose is to understand the
site
um
in a in a detailed way in terms of its
hydrogeology its stratigraphy and how
groundwater
um both from from a drainage surface
water and a groundwater drainage
standpoint but also contaminant
transport a lot of it is about making
sure that
a effective and protective groundwater
monitoring Network can be established
around the site and in order to do that
you need to have an understanding of
what the what the subsurface environment
looks like so you want to understand
what the stratigraphy is what the
layering and deposits of of uh you know
of sand and gravel and play and silt
might be because that helps instruct you
on how you on being able to demonstrate
that you can effectively monitor release
potential releases from the site and
then how to actually construct and
install that monitoring Network
oh one more follow-up yeah and
is the goal of that monitoring Network
to uh make sure that there is nothing
going into the groundwater at that site
or is it in terms of making sure that
nothing travels away from the site or is
it both
I think it's probably both what really
what what we're trying to do with any
landfill and and we start with the
designable landfill to ensure that
leachate from the landfill is is
collected effectively and and stored and
and and processed properly and that any
leachate that the landfill generates is
collected by in the first instance the
primary liner or failing that the
secondary liner and so the the
monitoring the groundwater monitoring
that we do around a landfill basically
there's a requirement to understand what
the current conditions are prior to
construction landfill cell in terms of
how groundwater flows but also what the
quality of the groundwater is so the
geochemical parameters of the
groundwater and then when you go into
modern you're required to do periodic
monitoring under your groundwater
release detection permit for a landfill
and then whenever you go concentrations
of any contaminants or geochemical
parameters
go above the established background that
launches the the applicant in the in the
holder of the permit into more intensive
monitoring to determine you know what
what this what the what the trend is and
and to determine whether there's been a
release from the landfill and then if
there's been a release from a landfill
there's a requirement to go into active
active remedial steps to to to to to
stop that release and contain it
thank you I have a question to piggyback
on that as well as your answer
so with what you've just described
how would you do that within a current
200 foot setback
well
what I think a lot of people don't
understand is that we have Century
monitoring Wells immediately adjacent to
the uh
landfill liner so basically if you were
to look at a footprint of a landfill
immediately adjacent to that often
within 50 feet of that there are
monitoring Wells that are monitored to
determine groundwater quality
immediately adjacent in outside of the
liner so those and
we we sometimes do see uh
detections of contaminants that cause
this concern
we've not seen them as a result of liner
leaks what we've seen is that in some
cases surface water runoff
um
from the landfill May May because of a
mistake or an error may contact waste
and and contribute some
uh contaminants to
to the groundwater it's or or in some
cases the surface water runoff that goes
into discharge basins surface water
infiltration basins around the landfill
and the good news is that we see those
results very very quickly and there
there are some examples of where we've
identified that and then required
immediately the landfill operator to
investigate they find out where the
mistake has been made or where the where
the problem is occurring they fix it and
then we see the groundwater restore the
ground to meet groundwater quality that
that the pre-existing groundwater
quality in many cases what we've
observed isn't even above a drinking
water standard it's just above what we
saw in the background groundwater and so
we see it early enough to then go and
require corrective measures and then we
continue to monitor as that groundwater
quality is restored to the background
quality and do you have an idea of how
long those corrective measures take to
implement
um
well I think it really depends on the
circumstance in many cases the actual
corrective measure doesn't take very
long it's the time taken to figure out
what's going on so in some cases we may
have several months or a few quarters of
monitoring before we actually get to the
bottom of the problem and then Implement
some kind of a solution
okay thank you
representative knabb thank you madam
chair
um do you know about when the 200 foot
setback was enacted and when was the
last time standards around landfall
sightings were
changed or updated
I'm sorry could you say the second part
of your question again I I'm just sort
of curious It's a history of regulations
around landfill citing so you have a 200
foot setback currently right right how
long has that been in existence and is
that the last time that
laws around landfill citing were updated
I think I I don't know how long that 200
foot setback has been there I know it's
been there for quite some time it's it's
many years I believe but I don't know
how many
um I don't believe we've had we did do a
rulemaking back in I think around 2014
where there was some setback
requirements but I don't believe they
were related to surface water I think
they were related to roads and
Residences and private property and that
sort of thing
um
representative Bixby so
do you think that 200 foot setback is
appropriate or do you think it needs to
be Revisited
well I I'm to be to be really candid I'm
anxious to see I I we are hopeful that
the study that's envisioned by Senate
Bill 227 will be
um will be will be implemented and and
I'm anxious to hear what a third-party
expert has to say about these setbacks
important to understand that the in
practice that setback has typically
really only been applied to
um
Wetland and and very minor surface water
features I don't think I don't think we
have
um
and I I'm really not aware that we have
any landfill footprints that are just at
200 just just at that setback 200 feet
from a particular surface water so it's
what I will tell you is that we don't
have examples of
um perennial surface water is being
impacted above surface water quality
standards by contaminants from the land
the currently operating landfills
thank you
representative Dotsy
uh thank you madam chair I just want a
point of clarification
um Mr wamsa did you say that
um based on this bill you would find it
hard to maybe cite any landfills in the
state
no I think thank you for the question
representative I think what I said was
that it's not clear to us if you
were to
implement this bill as introduced
whether
um what that what that would mean for
future landfill citing in the state
we're not sure that
um given the the way that New Hampshire
geology is and the way the occurrence of
surface waters in the state it's unclear
to us what sites might meet that the
criteria that are set out in this bill
sure yeah the reason I asked the
question is because we we've been given
a map
um based on uh only one seventh of New
Hampshire is excluded by The Five-Year
groundwater system
um and this the source was uh New
Hampshire Des 2011
um so I mean you know there's some kind
of a conflicting thing there certainly
is I'm familiar with that map I can tell
you that the gentleman at DES who made
that map was very dismayed to see how it
was being used with respect to a bill
last year and this year
um that as I understand it is a
stratified drift aquifer map it does not
purport to identify areas where
um a five-year travel time distance
would exist the reality is that that is
so site-specific we're not we don't have
anywhere near the information we would
need to make a map like that
um so that map is really being misused
and it's misleading people
thank you
representative germana
thank you madam chair uh my first
question is not having seen Senate Bill
227 what is the timeline on that bill in
terms of a report back
um my understanding well and I think
there's been a a
an amendment that combined the that bill
was Senate Bill 61. I've not had a
chance to sit down and read that
amendment I think the original version
of Senate Bill 227 uh puts it at about
uh completing the study on the order of
well in time to do rulemaking within two
years that's my understanding thank you
mate follow-up Madam chair yes uh thank
you and uh in general how long does it
take to to cite a landfill right so that
the legislation refers to any proposed
new landfill so roughly from the time
that you know a company were to propose
citing a landfill in the in the time
that that permission is granted roughly
how long does that take so that that's a
tough question to answer if you just
look at the law you would conclude that
um basically an application comes in and
if everything's perfect we approve that
we find the application complete within
60 days and then we render a decision
within 120 days in practice for the for
such a big undertaking as a proposing
and citing a newly I did Greenfield's
landfill the chances of that application
being complete upon first submittal are
slim not not because applicants do a
poor job of submitting but there's just
a lot that you have to provide so we
would do a review and determine what
things were missing and then we would
ask for those new information to be
provided and then that would come in and
then the clock starts over again in
practice uh it's it's probably a
two-year process um
I am going to warn you that we should
not be talking discussing Senate bills
especially we don't have anything in
front of us about it so
um I would like to suspend any
discussion about that Senate bills that
were considered or voted on please
hmm
any other questions from the committee
seeing none I want to thank you for your
testimony this afternoon
I'm sure yep
I would like to bring up Sebastian
Fuentes who said uh who is uh
from Woodlands Road and uh asked for one
minute to speak
good afternoon good afternoon Madam
chair and members of the community thank
you for uh taking my testimony today uh
my my primary my full-time job is a
movement politics director for rice and
democracy of New Hampshire I don't think
I put it on the sheet but I'm also a
resident of the North Country for the
last 22 years
when I moved to New Hampshire 21 years
ago uh you know I went straight to the
North country because it's a beautiful
area uh you know we have amazing Rivers
the parks uh you know all the activities
you can do there and uh and the reason
when I'm here is because we know about
this project that is happening or this
plan to be happening in the North
Country which is a Casella waste uh
landfill in the Dalton Whitefield area
near Forest Lake now uh while living in
the North Country I also performed a job
in the hospitality industry I worked for
two of the grand hotels of New Hampshire
which is the mountain view grand in
Whitefield and the omnivore Washington
and Breton woods so uh while doing that
job many times a guests will ask me uh
you know where can we go to enjoy the
you know the White Mountains the rivers
and the lakes and everything I always
send them to the Forest Lake Area I
always send them to the yamunus River or
the pemi River or the connect River
Connecticut River for fishing any other
activities I'm really concerned as the
resting of another country about what
this project might happen so that's what
I'm here to ask you the committee to
support HP 56 because I think that's the
reasonable thing to do uh you know and
also I keep thinking about
how can we think about placing a
landfill another one because we already
have one in Bethlehem New Hampshire in
the middle of the White Mountains of New
Hampshire which is one of our Prime
touristic attractions especially for
folks that work and Thrive from the
hospitality industry in the North
Country so I'm giving my testimonial as
a resident and giving my testimony as a
as a former um Hospitality manager that
I witnessed that if you go to Whitefield
and you stay at the mountain view grand
and you sit on the front porch you see
the area Forest Lake why why are those
people going to tell future guests when
they tell them that that mound or we're
looking at a brand where they're having
enjoying their meals and the drinks is
actually a landfill Mount so that's my
concern that's my what I'm bringing to
you today and I appreciate your time and
consideration thank you thank you any
questions from the committee
seeing none thank you I would like to
call up uh someone named Nikki I'm sorry
I can't uh decipher your last name if
you would please give your name and
spell it I'd appreciate it
so I should apologize for my handwriting
I'm Nikki delude Roy d-e-l-u-d-e-r-o-y
I'm a registered professional geologist
in the state of New Hampshire and I work
for a company called verdantis we are an
environmental Consulting and engineering
firm with an office here in Manchester
New Hampshire
thank you for the opportunity to speak
this morning
as a registered professional geologist
in the state I have worked with the
existing New Hampshire Des Solid Waste
regulations regularly throughout my
career I've been in the business for
about 20 maybe 25 years if I were honest
um I wanted to just kind of point out a
couple of things my written testimony
goes into greater detail but I did want
to cite that existing regulation EnV SW
80402 provides and I quote a landfill in
all Associated leachate Storage Unit
shall be located only in areas where
groundwater monitoring for release
detection characterization and
Remediation can be conducted prior to a
release having an adverse effect on
water supply
along with the remainder of
envsw804 these existing regulations
require an evaluation of site's proposed
hydrogeologic conditions
such that an applicant would need to
demonstrate that they could
detect characterize and remediate and
impact prior to having that adverse
impact on a sensitive receptor
to be able to do that
applicants tend to hire geologists like
myself to complete an investigation on
the property
these investigations are thorough and
quite frankly as um as uh director
wimsat referenced earlier are a
representation of a wide number of
Investigation
um uh sampling and Analysis
across the site and
those analyzes support a robust
understanding of what is especially in
the state of New Hampshire always a very
complex site hydrogeology and geology
one of the biggest challenges with House
Bill 56 is the reference to the maximum
seepage velocity being the highest rate
estimated for any test site in the
disposal area this requirement is
arbitrary and it does not reflect the
standard geologic and hydrogeologic
practices or real field conditions under
real conditions groundwater flow does
not follow a single highest value
velocity in the subsurface there are
always outliers in our data a high a
high-end area of gravel where there's a
high velocity represented by one single
measurement or conversely an area of
very low permeability where those that
single measurement is very low in an
outlier on the opposite end
use and consideration of a single
highest measurement is not
representative of those exact of those
real feel field field conditions rather
our thorough investigations of data
generally look at averages across the
site and work from there
HB 56 superficially appears to be more
protective but is actually arbitrary and
technically unjustified and it doesn't
take into account important scientific
analyzes that are typically completed
nor does it require or encourage a real
thorough analysis of site-specific
hydrogeologic data
in addition The Five-Year travel time
consideration included in HB 56 is also
arbitrary and without scientific or
technical justification and it's far
more conservative than is likely
necessary at many sites under existing
New Hampshire regulations the minimum
setback is 200 feet and I just want to
say that one more time it is not a
setback of 200 feet it is a minimum
setback
again the requirement for that setback
really ties back to can a applicant
monitor groundwater so that you could
detect remediate any impact in time to
prevent an adverse reaction or an
adverse impact
um establishing an arbitrary time of
travel requirement based on a single
maximum measurement at a site is not
protective it's just technically
unjustified and unscientific so for
those reasons I urge the committee not
to support hb56 thank you
thank you for your testimony
representative Bixby you have a question
yes thank you thank you for taking my
question thank you um
so uh you said that the 200 is the
minimum and that uh it would be
increased depending on the conditions
and to make it uh possible to remediate
what is the time required for for
remediation and how's that built into
the the actual setback that's
established that's a great question
um so you know to director wimsat's
references earlier it depends on the the
issue at hand right and so some issues
are much more readily available a
readily remediated and so that time of
travel could be very short but for a
typical sort of worst case scenario
there's lots of Technology available for
implementation and Remediation we do for
example pump and treat systems that can
make a big difference in a relatively
short amount of time and on the order of
a year or certainly in the order of
quarters if it's something easier to
remediate and address up front
follow-up and uh do you know what the
frequency of
of modern monitoring is so haven't you
haven't how much time passes between
each monitoring measurement
um typically it's on it's quarterly but
it really depends on the provisions of
the permit that's granted through the
Des
one more and uh if the uh if the ground
with the rate of groundwater flow were
uh very rapid from that from a site uh
would that be taken into account in the
process of saying what the setback would
be in in addition to the setback also in
what the monitoring Well Network would
it look like and again that's a
discussion between the applicant and Des
and basically Des is able to establish a
monitoring Network that reflects the
actual field conditions thank you
uh so I have a question
in your testimony you said the five-year
time of travel consideration included in
HB 56 is arbitrary and without
scientific or technical justification
and is far more conservative than is
necessary
so if it would not be a five-year time
of travel
what time of travel would you find as
being
not arbitrary
so one that really reflects like
conditions so I think the the trying to
select a certain number of years right
and I think for example Maine's
regulations actually reference six years
this is five years you know there's no
magic number to what how many years you
would need what you need is a robust
monitoring Network that is able to be
responsive you need a robust monitoring
schedule so that you can see if there's
an issue coming and give the applicant
and the operator of the landfill time to
address to work with des and address any
impact that might be there again to to
reiterate something uh director wimsat
said you know typically it is not
leaching from a landfill that's an issue
it's more of a surfacial there was a
some sort of storm water or surface
water impact to a monitoring location
and those are easy easier to address and
identify in a much shorter time period
thank you
representative NAB
thank you madam chair thank you for
coming in to testify today I just wanted
I was just curious if the New Hampshire
Board of Professional geologists
considered taking a position on this
bill
so my honest response is we meet
relatively irregularly and so I have not
brought that up to the board at all so I
don't know the answer and I'm certainly
not here in that capacity today
representative Creighton
I guess Madam chair thank you
um I appreciate your testimony I just
wanted to see if I understood what you
said with regard to monitoring so you
put the test well in
water's flowing through it you detect
bad stuff going through it
but at that point in time the landfills
already existed
so what would the remediation be if the
landfill was already existent
so it triggers whatever the you know
whatever the
level is that it would trigger and then
now you go back to the people and you
say Well it triggered it to remediate
how do you remediate if the landfill is
already there well there are lots of
there are lots of that's a great
question but there are lots of options
that we have at our disposal and we
often remediate impacts from say a
leaking underground storage tank for
example right and we use those
monitoring Wells to identify that there
is a leak from that you can do pump and
treat systems there are sort of chemical
additions to the ground that you can add
that help the natural biota breakdown
contaminant in in the groundwater sort
of in-sit you so there's lots of
remedial technologies that are available
should there ever be impacts identified
okay thank you ma'am you're welcome
any other questions
representative germana thank you uh and
thank you for taking my question kind of
piggyback on representative Creighton's
question and so that if an existing
landfill you know triggers that
mechanism and some of the remediation
efforts are put into place is there then
is is there a a longer range plan for a
landfill that triggers that type of
treatment so for example more frequent
treatments are more frequent uh testing
to make sure that uh the problem isn't
recurring so in other words is part of
the remediation plan
could you explain the remediation plan
and how it might play out over a period
of years of retesting Etc certainly I
think it's probably a great question for
Des representative to answer more
directly but
um I could imagine that if if I were
sitting at DES that one of the first
things I would require was additional
monitoring either additional analytical
requirements or more frequent testing in
the in the in response to an issue that
might have been identified
but that would really be driven by Des
right there they're The Regulators
any other questions
thank you so much for coming and
testifying today I'd like to call Erica
Perez
and you requested three minutes
good afternoon Madam chair and members
of the committee
um my name is Erica Perez I'm
representing New Hampshire youth
movement and today I'm representing
Alexa Newton who wouldn't be here today
um her testimony reads
good morning Madam chair and members of
the committee my name is Alexa Newton
and I am testifying today in support of
HB 56.
I was born and raised in Littleton New
Hampshire and I'm currently working to
obtain my associate's degree in
environmental science
recently I completed my final Capstone
student-led project and it was for my
attention focus on Casella Waste Systems
Corporation
and the new landfill site they have been
working to get approved to build in
Dalton New Hampshire many regulations
are already in place
when citing a new landfill such as the
current 200 foot buffer from the body's
water and monitoring the groundwater but
we need legislation that would give
communities more time to monitor
groundwater for one it could become
contaminated by a landfill
contaminations from landfills is
inevitable no matter how many layer
levels of linear
of liner are placed in the ground even
if it takes a hundred years for it to
start leaking the well-being of the
environment and the future generation
should always be taken into account when
the state considers permits for proposed
landfills new contaminations of water
bodies from landfills are still being
discovered such as the presence of pfas
which was found to have leaked into the
groundwater from the Bethlehem landfill
nces I owned and operated by Casella
the effect to be fast on humans and the
environment are still unknown as it is
still a recent discovery but this is
just one example of how these chemicals
have traveled through the groundwater at
this highly monitored landfill
there's no question that if the landfill
proposal in Dalton is approved the
groundwater would become contaminated
and in fact the wildlife of Forest Lake
State Park the proceeding clean water a
forest lake and the residents who live
near the area
the contaminated groundwater would also
affect my family and I as we have a
family lake house on Forest Lake and
have for multiple Generations
when I think of how contaminated water
would impact the lake wildlife and
people I know this is not the kind of
future I would wish anyone to have
to have to deal with just for the sake
of dumping our trash someplace HB 56
would not make it impossible to cite a
new landfill in New Hampshire if it is
needed nor would it make it impossible
for landfills for current landfills to
expand but it would mitigate the risk
posts to our lakes in rivers taking
present and future groundwater flow and
contamination into account is just as
important as any regulation when setting
a new landfill anywhere as a concern
represent of New Hampshire I urge you to
vote on to pass on HB 56 for the future
sake of New Hampshire's ground Waters
thank you for your time today
thank you any questions
thank you for your testimony
I would like to Now call Dr Adam Finkel
to come and testify if you've requested
five minutes
thank you I will definitely try to be
briefer than that I appreciate having
that much time if
if need be thanks for the opportunity to
explain why this third annual version of
a fix for the archaic and dangerous 200
foot setback between landfills and
vulnerable surface waters is the best
version yet and should be enacted I've
heard every conceivable objection to
fixing this simple problem and I'd be
glad it's time permits to answer any
questions about why every one of these
objections is untrue desperate and
Unworthy of your attention
I just want to make clear I'm a
supporter of safe and sane landfill
operations there was I believe only one
person who testified at the December
2021 hearing on the mount carvery
expansion you're looking at him and I
testified in favor of that expansion
because that site is hydrogeologically
sensibly cited
so I'll just give a few assertions I
don't like to make assertions as a
scientist but I'll be happy to take
questions for what HP HP 56 is and what
it is not
it is the way that the federal EPA and
many many U.S states have cited new
landfills for decades any
one-size-fits-all setback based on
distance ignores the simplest most basic
fact here contaminated groundwater can
flow as slowly as 20 feet per year in
good clay soil and solid Bedrock or as
rapidly as 20 feet per day in sand and
gravel and fractured Bedrock why on
Earth literally why on Earth would
anyone want to cite a landfill in the
wrong place when there are so many
places that can be cited safely
now uh director whimsat took a shot at
the map that we put together which I uh
handed out to you uh it is accurate it
is des's own data it does not say that
the green areas are all suitable and the
red areas are all unsuitable there'll be
places in the red area where uh it's bad
soil but far from water there'll be
places in the green area where it's good
soil but too close to water but on
average about 86 percent of our state is
good clay soil or solid Bedrock so the
idea that this will make landfilling
impossible is bizarre it will make
landfilling ever so slightly harder for
those people who who want to dig in a
sand pit next to a lake which is a crazy
idea to begin with so those people have
to look a little harder but it is not
capable of changing the supply and
demand for landfills the analogy I like
to use is every public swimming pool in
the country now has a little sign that
says Don't dive in the shallow low end
that doesn't change the supply and
demand and the enjoyment that people get
from swimming and Diving it says move 20
feet and don't break your neck it
doesn't change the price or the quantity
secondly
this is modeled on the experience of
site of states that have thriving
landfill Industries and safe sighting I
understand from people in Maine and from
the people in the industry I talk to who
operate in Maine that it's 25 years now
that they've had stricter guidelines
that HP 56 would have and their landfill
industry is thriving The Operators know
that they simply have to ignore or avoid
the very very worst possible sites third
it's proactive all landfills will leak
that's not just an old Mantra it's a new
mantra I handed out a one-pager with
recent peer-reviewed literature that
that says that the old Mantra that they
will leak is still true today there are
new landfills leaking and there are new
landfills that have not leaked yet
because they're new
and I'm not sure how really how lay
people if understand how massive the
amounts of contaminated leachate that
form because of the inherent materials
and the rainfall so I live on Forest
Lake it's about a mile in diameter
depending on how much rainfall is
infiltrating over the lifetime of a
landfill that would be could be cited
there enough leachate to completely fill
the Basin of that Lake between two and
seven times over
if you want to talk about a bigger Lake
it's four inches of leachate on top of
Lake the entire surface of Lake
Winnipesaukee these are billions of
gallons and to put it next to a river or
lake is to use a technical term nuts
the bill is responsive to Industry
uh request last year to add these
technological offsets to give them extra
travel time based on the main system if
someone wants to put the table of
offsets from Maine right into a bill
that's not up for me to say if Des wants
to develop its own rule for offsets
that's fine too
it absolutely exempts existing landfills
that wish to expand I appreciate I hope
we'll hear later today from Waste
Management Incorporated who had real
concerns with last year's bill and I
appreciate representative Mary working
with them to craft language that
absolutely makes 110 clear this does not
apply to to TurnKey it does not apply to
mount carvery
Etc
it is appropriately precautionary many
many environmental standards that's my
business for 40 years protect against
the reasonable worst case especially
when companies have every incentive to
collect data in ways designed never to
reveal worst case conditions
it's very odd to me that Mr Wimsatt
would say that that the maximum measured
value is quote erroneous if it's not
erroneous it is precautionary now we can
argue whether it's too precautionary but
what really troubled me last year right
before the the override vote the people
at the mount Carberry landfill said the
same thing in a letter to the governor
it's erroneous to use the maximum value
well I found that more than ironic
because the mount carvery application
both in its initial form 25 plus years
ago and its expansion request a few
years ago uses exactly that formula they
are very proud of being 150 years away
from the androscogen using the single
maximum measured value if you let the
company average they will keep
collecting data until their average goes
down to where they want it to be so
that's a good debate to have but don't
you dare call it erroneous it is not
erroneous it is precautionary and it's
appropriate
and finally this bill is overwhelmingly
popular as you know eighty percent of
your colleagues voted for last year's
bill
what is it not it's not arbitrary yeah
it could be six years like Maine it's
five years uh but realistically five
years is really not enough time New
Jersey uses 12 years it takes a long
time to find map and then fix God
willing if it can be fixed a plume that
is approaching surface water so I'd
prefer it be six or twelve but five is
it's a speed limit you know 56 miles an
hour 54 miles an hour we settle on 55 on
the interstate system
and as I said it is not capable of
raising prices cutting Supply or killing
jobs I wrote a book on this regulation
kill jobs the answer is generally no it
creates jobs in roughly equal proportion
but you can't harm the economy by making
it ever so slightly harder to find a
good site there will be another landfill
cited in the state we don't need one for
20 plus years but when we do we hope it
will be cited an appropriate place and
frankly this bill doesn't touch distance
but it would be nice if the next
landfill is not 150 extra truck miles
away from the sources of generation
adding more and more CO2 to the air
so I just have a few more sentences here
this bill is about 600 words long but
all it really says is when New Hampshire
needs a new landfill in 20 years or more
it can be put anywhere except in
hyperporous soil next to a lake or river
under the current 200-foot setback and
at the speed of groundwater flow that
our applicant and Dalton has already
measured itself a plume of toxic P fast
Laden leachate could reach a water body
in 13 days after which it could never be
restored without vast fast expense but
Des requires monitoring only every uh Mr
Roy said three months I've seen six to
12 month frequencies but it's way more
than 13 days
I hate the term Common Sense legislation
because everybody's idea of what's
common sense and what's what's common in
what sense varies but in this case where
the problem is so obvious the solution
is so easy I cannot accept anyone
claiming that the status quo makes sense
but it shouldn't be fixed before we make
a mistake that will reverberate in this
state for the next Century thank you
thank you any questions from the
committee
representative germano uh thank you
thank you for your testimony thank you
madam chair uh I take it from your
testimony that you don't believe that
current rules are as robust as uh Des
makes them out to be could you tell us
uh why you think that the current rules
are not adequate
so please understand this is a difficult
question for me personally because I've
been a bureaucrat for most of my life
I'm incredibly
uh enthusiastic supporter of the
bureaucracy but in this case the rules
are
farcical okay Des has 44 pages of citing
rules and many of them are very good but
but they deal with locate with a design
operation post closure the citing part
is one and a half pages it's 30 years
old and it's it's vague and it's archaic
no of you know no offense I made
mistakes when I was in the federal
bureaucracy but Des didn't even realize
that for 23 years the federal Congress
told them to update their setback
between airports and landfills the the
Congress passed a law in 2000 the
Wendell Ford act that said you have to
be six miles from an airport their rules
still say ten thousand feet they're just
not able to keep up with changing law
and changing technology and we learned
in the Concord Monitor a couple weeks
ago I was amazed I used to work for an
agency that had
OSHA we had six inspectors for the state
of Montana literally on the road 24 7
looking for uh to respond to problems
Des has one person
examining and inspecting the landfills
recycling centers transfer stations in
the state so no matter how good the
rules are and they're not good uh
there's not enough money to enforce them
so I hate to say it that way but it's a
it's a softball question
thank you thank you madam chair thank
you any other questions seeing none no
no representative Bixby so
um
one of the issues that's come up right
one of the issues that uh sort of
emerging in terms of landfills uh is uh
the amount of uh pfas and leachate and I
was wondering if um
that needs some further level of
protection than what a what might have
been required in the past
well sure it does and this is a terribly
vexing problem because I have real
Sympathy for the landfill industry their
trade Association swanna put out a
letter to Congress a few months ago they
are going to be asking for legislation
that would give relief to landfills for
Downstream pfas contamination because it
is ubiquitous it is something that we as
consumers have asked for over many
decades but that doesn't change the fact
that these landfills are Laden with
consumer products that contain pfas and
yes we need we need much more stringent
monitoring for those chemicals more
frequent but again the best solution is
not to cite improperly so that we're
having to deal with 13 days or three
months or for 4.9 years of time to find
and fix
follow-up so um you also mentioned
earlier that
um
there is a uh the the amount of uh
leachate that um is in landfills because
of the rain water deposition Etc is
enormous and I'm wondering uh how is
that they must have some some method for
for removing it how is that removed and
what safeguards are there
for making sure it doesn't get out of
hand and what's the backup if it does if
it does spill or something
well so it's two different issues one is
underground uh failure uh now the the
expected operation as you know is that
is that leachate collects between the
liners and it's constantly being pumped
out and trucked uh you know sometimes
many hundreds of miles to a place where
it can be treated that's the expected
operation and that will have to go on
for decades after the landfill is closed
because of the continuing production of
leachate from the from the waste but as
you say there are also surface spills
like the one we had in Bethlehem last
two years ago and then there are
failures so the peer-reviewed literature
I handed out on the one pager says that
the the
geosynthetic plastic liners crack they
crack upon installation and they crack
in the ground later and also the
compacted clay layers that are often
trucked in from off-site crack so there
needs to be a a second level of
monitoring much deeper than anybody has
monitored before uh but again this is a
cons it's called a bathtub it's a
constant
outflow which needs to be gathered and
treated and there's I think there's no
way to avoid that it's a question of
where do you put them so that the the
material can be pumped off and treated
and not get in the environment thank you
thank you any other questions
thank you for your money appreciate it
I'd like to call Nancy Morrison
who's requested two minutes
um
good day I'm Nancy Morrison but I'm here
today to read a statement from
Haley Jones who took ill last night and
is not able to be here today to give
testimony so I'm here to read it for her
um do you have it written to hand out to
the committee I do not I think you've
written in my own illegible handwriting
but I have shortened it
um because of respect for your time
today thank you appreciate it yes so
thank you madam chair and esteemed
members of the House committee on
environment and agriculture my name is
Haley Jones
and I am the Vermont and New Hampshire
state director with slingshot where we
work alongside communities most impacted
by environmental threats to take aim at
polluters and build community power
Statewide and regionally we bring
Community groups together to advocate
for broader change to make sure no
Community has to suffer a same problem
again
I am here today along with Community
leaders from across the state to testify
in support of House Bill 56 a bill that
sets proven science-based landfill
setbacks to protect our water bodies
Recreation areas and human health
many others will speak to the economic
and environmental benefits of this bill
so today my testimony will focus on
public health ramifications
we know as you've heard today that all
landfills leak discharging leachate into
the surrounding soils where this garbage
juice can travel with concerning speed
when landfills are cited on porous or
otherwise unsuitable terrain the
dangerous leachate can contaminate
Community water sources before
Regulatory Agencies have a chance to
respond
what are the consequences of this
contamination
after seeping through piles of waste
leech 8 is carrying lead arsenic heavy
metals and toxic forever chemicals like
pfas all of which present serious public
health concerns pfas alone are
associated with Cancer's reproductive
disorders
serious developmental problems
so it's clear that we need to prevent
their spread whenever possible
instituting landfill setbacks based on
the five-year distance of travel
estimates is a simple science-based way
to minimize this potentially devastating
landfill problem
New Hampshire has learned the hard way
with pfas and other industry toxins that
the best approach to prevent harmful
pollution is to act before it happens
passing Common Sense legislation like
House Bill 56 while funding waste
reduction programs and decentralizing
local waste management will ensure a
livable healthy and sustainable future
for New Hampshire
thank you so much for your time and I
encourage you to vote ought to pass on
this critical and time-sensitive piece
of legislation sincerely Haley Jones New
Hampshire state director director for
slingshot
thank you thank you any questions from
the committee seeing none thank you and
I call Wayne Morrison
and please if
if you've heard something already that
is in your testimony please
skip it because we've heard it
foreign
thank you appreciate it you're getting a
double dose of the Morrison family so I
hope you'll survive the the two of us
both delightful
um
circling around uh there's there's two
pieces of testimony I'm giving to you
one of them is from a licensed
hydrogeologist by the name of Muriel
Robinette
Muriel couldn't be here today but she
has testified in the past on similar
bills she is an independent
hydrogeologist with over 40 years of
experience in New Hampshire and has also
spent significant amount of time in
Maine
and I share this with you because there
are differences of the opinion that you
heard facts earlier today Muriel
strongly suggests uh supports this bill
and the key elements that uh would
described here a few minutes earlier so
I'm not going to speak to this but I
wanted to see I wanted you to have her
testimony and Muriel would certainly be
available for any follow-up later
I would also start by saying you've
heard a lot today about remediation
and I think that's a really important
point
but a lot of what house bill 56 is all
about is really prevention and
protection
I'm going to spend a little bit of my
time talking about both of those items
so for the record my name is Wayne
Morrison and I serve as president of
North Country Alliance for balance
change if you haven't heard of ncabc we
are a collection of local residents who
have banded together
with the expressed Focus to try and
promote both environmental and economic
uh best interests of New Hampshire's
North Country
over the past few years ncabc has been
very active in promoting legislation
would that would assist the Department
of Environmental Services in updating
its citing regulations for new Solid
Waste landfill facilities
We Believe
just as Vermont Maine Massachusetts and
other New England states have done
that our current arbitrary one-size-fits
all 200 foot setback regulation is
inadequate unprotective and in fact
dangerous
New Hampshire enacted the current
200-foot setback requirement between
landfills and perennial bodies of water
over 30 years ago
a lot has changed since 1991.
yet despite advances in technology and
science and our growing understanding of
the increased health safety and
environmental risks involved our setback
criteria for citing new landfills has
remained unchanged
in 1991 no one knew about the dangers of
pfas and many other toxic chemicals now
found in landfill leech leachate but
today we do
we can't go back in time but we can take
decisive action now to protect New
Hampshire's future
now in fact is the perfect time to get
this right
there are currently no applications for
new landfill developments sitting before
Des
and the solid waste biennial report
published in November of 2022 concludes
that there is sufficient landfill
capacity through at least 2034 and in
all likelihood well beyond
House Bill 56 ensures that the next new
landfill development in New Hampshire
whenever that becomes necessary will be
cited safely and with the best science
information and Technology we now have
available
House Bill 56 ensures site-specific
criteria and requires no testing that
applicants don't already do
this bill doesn't ban new landfills
doesn't restrict how many landfills we
ultimately have
it provides language making it crystal
clear that it doesn't apply to existing
landfills or expansions of existing
landfills
House Bill 56 provides the state of New
Hampshire with the opportunity to ensure
the sighting of new landfills is
science-based and provides real
protection for some of the most valuable
and irreplaceable resources we have
we don't need additional studies and
commissions to know what we have to do
all we need to do is look around to our
neighboring states to realize that what
we currently have is woefully inadequate
let us not forget that despite the
latest technology available and the best
intentioned landfill operators
accidents occur leachate spills
people make mistakes
switches and valves fail doubled line
materials deteriorate and leaks
inevitably happen
when they do the only thing protecting
our rivers lakes wetlands and drinking
water supplies from a landfill's toxic
leachate chemicals is the setback
distance regulation you have before you
today
the next new landfill will have
generational impacts on our state and
local communities
and we owe it to the people of New
Hampshire to make sure we get it right
I asked this committee to act now and
enthusiastically support house bill 56.
I have no idea what is going to happen
in the Senate and which bill is going to
pass
I do know that before you today
is is an act that we can take that will
significantly improve the protections
that our current regulations don't
provide
I applaud des and the effort to go and
study this subject in more detail I
encourage them to take whatever time is
necessary to get it right
but we know today that 200 feet is
miserably inadequate and we should fix
that now while other work goes on there
is no reason not to go forward with this
house bill 56 it will immediately make
New Hampshire's environments safer and I
ask for your support thank you thank you
Mr Morrison any questions from the
committee
being none thank you again
I'd like to call Dana newt
and you've requested two minutes
good afternoon and welcome thank you
thank you madam chair and committee
members my name is Dana Newt I'm from
San Martin proud to say we now have more
people than cows there a long time
coming I'm here representing business I
have a business here in Concord Museum
buildings group excuse me and our
mission is to for clean energy click
clean air and clean water
excuse me
and I I'll take any questions but I I
just I want to disclose I'm a member of
the ncabc now
and
um representing business I think they
need to expand so I'd be glad to take
any questions but I'm for both 56 and
602.
thank you any questions from the
committee representative Bixby
yes so uh We've we've heard
um a lot of Health perspectives and
environmental perspectives what uh is
your particular business perspective on
this being a good bill or these these
bills being good again we're a major in
uh clean energy but also clean air and
clean water and I feel that this is a
very important bill for any waterway in
New Hampshire again to build within 200
feet it's ridiculous
thank you yep any other questions
thank you Mr Newt thank you
and I'll call Henry vayu
from Waste Management
good afternoon and welcome good
afternoon uh Madam chair and members of
the committee for the record my name is
Henry vayu and I'm here on behalf of
Waste Management
Waste Management owns and operates the
turkey landfill in Rochester in the past
we've had this committee to the landfill
for a tour we'd be happy to do something
similar at your leisure in your schedule
as it permits uh but um I'm just here to
address the issue of uh this bill in
this issue and uh whether it applies to
expansions of landfills
in last year's Bill
there was some language that I think the
sponsors intended
to exempt
and not have the bill applied to
expansions of landfills but the way it
was worded and the terms that it used
and the words in the existing
Des rules
made it somewhat ambiguous and so we at
the end of the session last year had
urged the governor to veto the bill for
that reason
um
I have seen uh
language that I think went into the
office of legislative services
for the amendment that I believe that is
before you I don't have the amendment
before me uh but I have a copy of the
amendment in front of me
oh
they're all gone but it says there is a
paragraph here that says nothing in this
paragraph shall be construed to prohibit
the expansion or modification of any
landfill facilities on any site on which
as of December 1st 2022
a r c r a subtitle D landfill exists
that has been fully permitted and that
is actively accepting waste
so I believe
um
representative Murray that this does not
apply to existing landfills
nice you know it's it's fine I'm I'm
just directing the question to you
yeah that's what the amendment is okay
thank you for clarifying that and I I
would just state that uh we would feel
this clarifies it a lot better uh than
last year's language and uh we'd feel
more comfortable uh with the language
that is provided in the amendment thank
you it makes it clear that it wouldn't
apply to expansions of
landfills okay thank you any other
testimony you'd like to give that is it
okay
um members of the committee any
questions
representative Bixby
so
um as as uh
as a business as someone in the waste
management business or representing some
that that um
do you feel that it makes sense to have
substantial setbacks between uh newly
created landfills and uh surface water
bodies
um so our landfill has been in operation
for decades
um
it has as uh director whimsat described
a very
um
we think adequate monitoring system
around it's it's a Line Landfill state
of the art landfill it has uh the
monitoring Wells uh to we think
determine whether there needs to be any
action taken there has never been uh any
issue that has caused alarm
um
so we think
you know we're operating under what is
sufficient
um you're asking about
um
you know permitting of new landfills and
do we need
um
different rules going forward
I'm not prepared to address that whole
issue today
um I
I don't have the technical expertise to
but I just wanted to get on the record
that as far as you know the concern that
we had last year about the ambiguity
with regards to the language on the
expansions that this seems to make it
much clearer that's all follow-up so um
I've read somewhere that uh that your
that waste management is doing
pre-treatment of leachate for pfas
before it leaves the site is that
something that you think should be more
commonly done
um I'd be happy to have someone come in
to talk to the committee about it again
um okay not not not in your pay grade
not on my pages all right thank you
thank you um I have a question as to uh
are there any specific materials that
you turn away from your landfill that
you won't accept well there there's a
list of materials uh in the statute that
are banned yard waste
um you know hazardous materials
um so the statute does provide some
direction of what can it you know uh
certain batteries
um
you know there are things are numerated
in the statute
um
okay
uh representative Howard
thank you madam chair
um I I I'm a little bit curious about
how far what is the furthest distance
that the garbage trucks come from to to
put um waste in your landfill
um you know it's it's a regional Solid
Waste Market
um there obviously is some out-of-state
waste that comes in
um
um I don't know from exactly how far you
know the fire this point that uh one
comes but
um you know it's something that uh uh
communities all over have to take into
consideration in terms of the cost that
usually comes down to the class and so
for uh some places far away it's the
trucking cost and how much it costs to
transport it uh the distance and what is
available in their state and what's the
Tipping fee uh um in their state for
their landfill sites so it does vary
um
how to know that answer your question
but I asked quick follow-up follow-up
sure
um so the someone I started earlier that
we have adequate
um uh um landfill
capacity now would you agree with that
so uh the turkey landfill has capacity
until I think it's June of 2034.
um now to get something permitted is not
something overnight it takes a long time
to get the application to get all the
testing done to prove to the department
uh that they should provide the permit
so you need you obviously need some lead
time
um Waste Management has more land that
they own that I'm sure at some point in
time they're
going to be asking for a permit to
expand to those other areas so there is
potential
um at the turkey landfill in Rochester
to have it go beyond
2034 but
with if we didn't get another permit to
expand uh we'd be shutting down uh June
of 2034.
representative Bixby
so um just to a little bit more clarity
on the permitting process is it is it
correct that permits are typically
issued for something like 10 to 15 years
or maybe 20 years I don't remember the
exact number and that and that there's a
constant process of renewal of the
permit so you would not you would never
get a permit forever you'd have to you
have to renew those over a period of
time and if you have the capacity it is
generally within the at least what we've
seen previously without with your
landfill and other ones that those
permits are granted if there's no
significant impediment I know uh the
current uh permit that we have there's a
depletion schedule
so the company can't just fill it up in
year one or two there has we the cut
we've committed to have that capacity
till June of
2034 and so you have to keep careful uh
attention to how quickly it's filling
because there is a commitment in the
permit to have the capacity for the
state's needs until June of 2034. so I
don't know if that totally answers your
question but it does address
that there's a guarantee that there will
be space there for the state's needs
right
but I I just wanted to be clear that
that's not the uh end date for
everything that's the end date for the
current president for the Kermit it all
things being equal it's likely that
you'd get another one
we hope so
representative germano thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
so as I'm thinking about how New
Hampshire compares to some of the states
around us in terms of some of these
regulations one of the other things that
comes to my mind in terms of what makes
us different from some of the
surrounding states is we take uh items
right in our landfills that other states
have already banned from their landfills
correct uh different states
have different
um laws with regards to what can go I
know in Vermont
um for instance uh they uh ban uh food
waste over certain uh you know
representative ebill's bill that she
brought in is modeled after Vermont and
so uh yeah certainly there there are
other states that ban things uh that go
into landfills that uh the state of New
Hampshire hasn't done yet
a follow-up follow-up thank you madam
chair and I believe there was a recent
article I forget where I read it about
it for example we also take mattresses
correct which some other states will not
allow mattresses to be disposed of in
landfills and it would seem to me that
that also introduces a problem uh
there's a reason why those states have
banned substances like mattresses from
being put in landfills and so how do we
take into account the types of chemicals
for example uh that are in some of these
substances that are not allowed to be
put into landfills in other states but
that we do allow here in New Hampshire
so uh you know the the
landfills today have to have uh the
collection system for the leachate
um we pre-treat it
um so
um you know I think we tried to the best
that we can
um address that issue uh but certainly
uh materials that uh go in uh do have
some uh
uh
you know pfas and whatnot
thank you thank you madam chair any
other questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
this afternoon
and I would like to call Eric
steinhauser
to come and speak
good afternoon Madam chair chairman
um committee members thank you for
hearing my testimony I realize time is
short so I will not read my whole
written I will highlight some things for
the record my name is Eric steinhauser
I'm a senior Pro senior vice president
and principal with the firm Sanborn head
and Associates we're a local Concord
firm specializing environmental and
geosciences
um our firm serves both public and
private clients in New England and
throughout the United States we also
work for the Des and the Department of
Transportation
personally I'm a professional engineer
with over 35 years experience in the
fields of civil environmental
remediation geotechnical and solid waste
engineering I'm a licensed professional
engineer in New Hampshire in 15 other
states I hold National certifications
and erosion control and stormwater
quality and I've been working in New
Hampshire for the last 18 years
also for the record please know that I'm
a member a council member of the New
Hampshire Waste Management Council
representing licensed Engineers I also
represent the Council on the New
Hampshire Southwest working group I want
to be clear that my testimony today is
based on my personal professional
experience as a landfill designer and
not for the council or the working group
these thoughts and opinions are not
theirs or just mine
um HP 56 references
um there were some comments about uh
whether this applies to expansions
I suggest that's a question for Des the
term new landfill in my experience with
Des is any new capacity that's in the
state is how they view that so uh
definitions for expansions need to be
very clear
um also like to point out that like
everyone else here I'm very concerned
about the environment and how we humans
affect our planet we all create waste
and we contribute to the need for
landfills in responsible disposal my
career is focused on remediating
contaminated properties and developing
technically sound environment
environmentally protective Sal waste
disposal facilities
it would be nice if we didn't need
landfills and I can focus my practice on
cleaning up dirty sites unfortunately
our modern society and standards for
living require us to have a final
repository for materials that can
otherwise be reused recycled or
otherwise managed so that landfills
aren't needed until such time you live
in a truly a true Society of no ways
that we will need landfills and these
facilities must be properly located
designed constructed and operated so
future Generations don't have to clean
up after us
in New Hampshire and other states which
I'm a licensed licensed professionals
are bound by a code of ethics makes us
responsible to human health and the
environment we accomplished these goals
of ethics and design by following rules
and codes guidelines and Engineering
judgment based on industry standard
scientific evaluations
Technologies and standards of practice
since I've been in practice there have
been countless Publications about
landfills both Pro and pecan
um but the overwhelming consensus of
these technical studies is that properly
designed constructed in operated
landline landfills are protective of the
environment independent of their
location
contrary to other statements you may
have heard excessive testing and
research is documented that geosynthetic
components of line landfills can have
service lives of hundreds of years
as proposed HB 56 would override the
existing setback criteria with the
statutory requirement
the time of travel
um
requirements are as we have heard are
exerted exerted from the state of Maine
Sal waste rules not law
given the differences with other aspects
of the main rules and their statutes it
is not prudent to selectively cut and
paste language from one State's rules
into New Hampshire's legislation
furthermore HP 56 would require the Des
to establish new definitions and
procedures to evaluate the quote project
Improvement allowances unquote to reduce
the potential travel times
please understand that creating such a
statutory framework for landfill citing
establishes a one-size-fits-all
condition that eliminates the
application of good science and
engineering in essence the requirements
of HB 56 have not been evaluated as
being appropriate for New Hampshire and
do not consider the impact of existing
rules in other citing criteria and
therefore is unjust unjustifiably
limiting
having
um
you've heard lots of testimony already I
don't want to repeat it about the value
of the five-year setback and the use of
a maximum one-time value that on the
site that might not be applicable to
groundwater flow or actually even the
location of performance of the landfill
I don't want Insurance my written
testimony I don't want a believer of
your time with that but basically using
the highest rate value to calculate a
travel time distance is is an excessive
um method compared to our traditional
approach a risk analysis and factors of
safety
I also want to point out that the
project proven allowances in Maine in
their rules
um allow for items that the New
Hampshire rules already have built into
our system for example Maine has a
single line of requirement you can have
a double liner requirement to read as a
project allowance we require in this
state a double liner system so how we
would actually go about reducing that
potential five-year is is not clear and
unknown and puts a lot of burden on the
Des and I think we'll re will result in
potential primitive Peels and possible
litigation on permanent applications in
the future
I feel that HP 56 takes a cherry picking
approach to development of landfills it
promotes an unrealistic approach to the
practice of engineering
in the state of New Hampshire and
eliminates the design professionals
ability to reasonably apply
site-specific data industry standards
guidelines and Engineering judgment to
the siding and designing of
environmentally protective landfills
my professional opinion HP 56 will not
improve the Environmental Protection of
blind landfills in New Hampshire rather
it will ensure that no new no new
disposal capacity will be permitted in
the state which is not prudent for the
state of New Hampshire's solid waste
needs in the future
thank you and I welcome any questions
thank you Mr steinheiser um
representative Bixby
the question yes so um is it your
feeling that uh it would be impossible
to find a site in New Hampshire that
would meet the criteria of HB 56
thank you for your question
um probably not however the resulting
site that might be available to develop
only if it might not be practical to
develop if you look at any of the the
landfills in the state they have and
you've talked about some of this already
wastewater treatment plants on site they
have lots of infrastructure around them
to handle landfill gas and in other
components to run a well operated
landfill so to have that capital
expenditure for all those incendiary
facilities that have a very small
disposal capacity it would not work it
would not pencil out to develop a
landfill there
thank you
representative coulon
thank you madam chair and thank you for
your testimony
um I'm just curious in your opinion what
would be
uh good language to let a community
respond to
um you know potential landfill citing in
their area
thank you for your question
um I think the rules and the procedures
that Des has for public input in public
need already built into the permitting
process there was a discussion about the
permitting process a landfill needs to
provide only enough capacity as the
state has need within a I believe a
20-year period
does it mean it solves all the needs for
that 20-year period but it has to show a
public need and there's when any new
disposal capacity in the state it's
required to have a public hearing
there's public comments to the
applications and there's a appeal
processes as well so I believe the
community has and has
been able to respond to those issues
with applications
any other questions representative
Creighton
uh yes sir thank you for your testimony
thank you madam chair
and you've said it but I just how would
you respond to testimony
that we've heard this afternoon that
says that this is
um scientific and
accepted practice yeah I know you said
in your testimony but I just
I'm trying to understand exactly you
know we've heard numerous testimonies
that this is scientific that it is
accepted practice that it is acceptable
and then we have other testimonies
saying the opposite so how would you
respond to that thank you for your
question
um
technical terms in math does not make
something scientific
um the approach to citing a landfill in
the design behind it goes through a lot
of evaluation
um and a lot of scrutiny by the Des
it's a years-long process to to go
through this even on the simpler sites
what Maine has proposed as as their
criteria has a number of caveats to it
allowances to reduce maybe to zero that
setback criteria
so just pulling their rules without
definition of how allowances are made
is is
incomplete at best
um and as I've said the and as you can
see in our rules we already have many of
those allowances built into requirements
that we have now for our landfills so
I'm not sure what else we would have to
do
or what Des would have to come up with
to allow for additional
um
approaches and evaluations to to allow
for allowances
appreciate your testimony representative
germano
thank you madam chair thank you for your
testimony for taking my question I'm
going to piggyback on representative
Creighton's question about the science
and of course the the word scientists I
think hate the most is arbitrary uh and
so my question to you is which is more
arbitrary a foot measurement 200 feet or
a measurement of the velocity of a
seepage it would seem to me that a a 200
foot
um distance is is a much more arbitrary
measure than the speed at which one
the water moves thank you to your
question
um sometimes I qualify my answers when
you ask an engineer a question that
they'll answer with it depends so it
depends
um both measurements are not arbitrary
they're set measurements
um it's what you're going to use that
measurement for I don't know the basis
of the 200 foot setback for
um the landfill Edge to the the Waterway
um
the measurement of seepage velocity I'm
not a hydrogeologist so I don't do that
measurement I'm not quite sure how you
do that so the actual methodology and
calculation of that could have some
um
let's say disagreement scientifically I
don't know how you would do that
personally
um so
the arbitrary comment would be you just
pick a number and apply it so I would
say both could be arbitrary because
you're picking a value that is ultra
conservative might and I have in my
written testimony it might be an outlier
value and applying it just as you would
apply the 200 feet
you might get the same answer
um but you might not so which approach
you take either one could be arbitrary I
think the the comments about fully
understanding the site and how it works
hydrogen hydrogeologically topography
like
um and and what else you can do for that
site to make the system the landfill
work is not an arbitrary procedure
thank you and thank you madam chair
representative Contour
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
uh just piggybacking on all of this
arbitrary
um The Five-Year setback uh travel
setback is exactly that a five-year
travel setback but the minimum but the
200 foot setback is only a minimum so
that can be adjusted so that really is
cannot be considered in my opinion would
you consider that arbitrary because it's
going to be based on every single site
thank you for your question I'm not sure
how to answer that
um there are lots of criteria in the
solid waste rules
um maybe it's only a page and a half but
there's a lot of criteria we have to
follow
when you add on all the criteria and you
start laying out what um the ultimate
limits of a landfill development could
be
um it becomes less arbitrary because
you're you're compounding uh criteria so
uh yes they are minimums
um
but depending on how the site looks and
how you want to operate it those
minimums are minimums and that's where
you start and then you develop from
there
representative Bixby yes so um in Maine
uh I'm not sure whether it's just in
statute or rules but uh they do not
allow any landfill citing on highly
porous soil do you think that makes
sense
thank you for your question that makes
sense for Maine
um they defined those geologic types
very specifically
um again I'm not the higher geologist so
I'd rather not comment on what those
definitions are but they are very
specific to very specific areas as I
understand it so it makes sense for me
representative Darcy
Madam chair
um and this question is just to help me
put this in context
um
I'm on a Conservation Commission and and
so we've worked with Sanborn head in the
past uh so my question to you is to
Sanborn and head have any contracts with
New Hampshire Des or have you ever
worked for New Hampshire Des thank you
for your question I have it in my
testimony that we are a consultant to
Des
as well as a DOT
thank you any other questions from the
committee
no seeing none
I do not have any more pink cards for
um
HB 56 if anybody else wishes to speak to
this bill please
okay
be kind
we need your pink card sir members of
the committee we need your pink card
please
just pass it can someone take that up
for me please thank you
thank you madam chair Preston for
recognizing me I asked to speak on the
second bill but I'm not going to speak
on that bill I'll take my two cents
worth right now and take my chances
my name is Clark horse and I'm uh
affiliated with collaborative solo waste
strategies a new New Hampshire
non-profit which hopes to serve as a
catalyst for different ways of looking
at landfills and incineration in our
state please speak into the microphone
so that the folks at home can hear thank
you thank you
unlike the scientists and the engineers
and the doctors and
experts that previously testified this
afternoon I never went to Harvard but I
can assure you a lot of habits gone
through me
I was a lobbyist in this in this state
for 42 years
and was
probably principally responsible for
killing over 68 bottle bills
but times have changed that was 1971.
that's when I started
this building was a post office at that
time
the first five speakers today all
mentioned the words remedial we can do
this we can take care of this if if if
we have a problem we have Solutions in
place where we have remedial actions I
ask you
why don't we take a preventive action by
passing these bills today or some
combination that you deem necessary
with respect to waiting for the Senate
why wait for the Senate all revenue
raising bills in this General Court have
to originate in the lower body
in my estimation you're not the lower
body you're the you're the
you're the big body
and this committee is critically
important to the future of our state and
your grandchildren and my great great
grandchildren I'm old enough to be most
of your grandfathers
old enough to be most of our grandfather
to most of you is what I intended to say
200 feet
is about how far I hit the ball off of
the ladies tee at Nashua Country Club
the distance from a pitcher's mound the
distance from home plate to second base
and back the home plate is about 200
feet
would you want your grandchildren
playing in a playground within 200 feet
of a landfill
professor
Finkel
spoke to Common Sense
I ask you to consider Common Sense today
these bills are critically important Des
is hamstrung
they can only do what they're told to do
they can only do with the staff that
they have to do with
it was mentioned that there's one
on-site landfill person that handles the
entire state
does that give you a feeling of comfort
it doesn't me
I'll testify I'll conclude my testimony
now I just ask you
to ask yourselves
what's at stake
for the future of our state I wish to
God 2 000 feet a 200 feet was 2 000 feet
it would make me feel a lot better and
those that follow me
I'll take any questions
thank you Mr Corson uh I just wanted to
uh verify you had said that you put in a
pink card for the next bill I did and
I'm I'm going to leave the building
for the sake of my safety after my
testimony so I won't be testified I'm
sure you'll be safe sir I would just I
would just say one more thing if I could
my good friend Henry vayu represents
Waste Management
I think waste management is compared to
the other private
landfill operator in this state heads
and shoulders
above the one that's trying to ruin the
the section that you call Dalton on the
river
but he said he had an amendment prepared
or an amendment had been prepared which
Waste Management felt much more
comfortable with
I would hope that he had said we
strongly Advocate the passage of some
combination of 50
6 and 602 today and take a more
affirmative position
with that said I'll conclude my
testimony I really appreciate you
letting me speak thank you sir anyone
else have questions for Mr Corson
thank you for joining us today
appreciate it
uh I have no other pink cards anyone
else interested in in speaking or or
against this bill
seeing none I will close the hearing on
HB 56.
uh does anybody need a few minutes break
yes we'll take uh yeah oh I'm sorry yeah
I need the blue sheet um from up there
yes thank you um online in the uh online
portal we have 423 people in favor of
this bill two in opposition
and the um
on the blue sign up sheet we have two
it's 18 12 14 people uh in favor and one
person opposed
so we will take a five minute break and
uh then we will come back
thank you so much okay good enough
oh yeah
yeah
oh yeah the geologists
and
Peter house along this way
yeah right here
economy
thank you very much
exactly
20 minutes
of course
is
no the dates
it's
foreign
all right
please
so what's your name
what's your name
representative Simon
foreign
okay I'd like to get our committee
settled please everybody take your seats
I'm asking everybody to please take
their seats
we want to get back underway here
Matt did you fill out a pink card I did
yes I just handed it to you
you were still making announcements
there you go
okay thank you you're welcome
hey
all right I would like to open up the
hearing on hb602 relative to landfill
citing and to introduce the bill today
to us is representative Matthew Simon
welcome thank you very much Madam chair
and thank you members of the n a
committee for the record my name is
representative Matthew Simon I represent
Grafton district one Littleton Lisbon
Lyman Sugar Hill bath and Monroe I am
here today to introduce you hb602 and as
I often sit in the seat that you are in
I recognize how difficult it is to hear
two bills like this in one right after
the other but what I do have for you
today and now I understand the reason
for it coming to my attention is Maine
statute so we've heard a lot today about
Maine statute the specifics of Maine
statute comparisons to Maine statute and
that is much more specifically fleshed
out in hb602 so I would just like to
walk you through a couple of pieces of
that I'm then happy to take any
questions that I am
capable of answering if you turn to page
two
um
the first through line 10 really deals
with some differences between this bill
and the last bill as far as the soil
composition specifically under where the
waste is going to be is going to
accumulate and as one of the previous
speakers towards the end said Maine does
have stringent requirements as far as
the soil composition directly underneath
the landfill itself and if you look at
line seven number three it says the area
within the solid waste boundary shall be
located on soils with sufficient fine
and clay-sized particles to minimize
leachate infiltration every measurement
made and into two soils within the
property shall have an undisturbed
hydraulic conductivity less than or
equal to one times 10-5 centimeters per
second my understanding of this and
talking with people in Maine is that
that measurement basically indicates
that if the hydraulic conductivity of
that level of soil is in place or less
than it would take about uh stuff would
travel about 10 feet per year so if you
have a thousand foot setback it would
take 100 years for that
um to try stuff to travel that far
um it was believed at the time that at
least at the last hearing that Maine had
on this issue uh to kind of review these
policies that
landfills are in use and are at a higher
level of leaking for about a hundred
years and so they felt like if you came
up with a calculation that took 100
years to get to a location you've
basically given it a lifetime protection
to
um
the significant water sources or well
sites whatever you have aquifers that
that you want to protect and so you'll
see some of those setbacks come up
further on down the page uh specifically
point to
um
line 27 and line 29 you'll see that
thousand foot sect back that's that's
the basic reason behind that setback and
how they came up with it in line 14 and
line 16 you'll see 300 foot setbacks
those are those are for a bit of a
different purpose one is from roads
one's from the property boundary they
felt like it gave them an adequate
amount of space
to both test for leakage and for
remediation so they want to be able to
remediate that before it hits a road so
that they don't have to deal with the
road they can deal with it before it
hits the road they don't want to have to
deal with it after it goes over the
property boundary they want to be able
to deal with it inside the property
boundary as far as my understanding is
goes that was kind of the rationale for
the 300 foot setbacks there and then you
have in line 18 I'd just like to point
out a minimum thousand foot setback
between the solid waste boundary and the
nearest Residence not owned by the
applicants at the time the application
is filed for the with the Department
that has absolutely nothing to do with
groundwater at all
um I think that's basically in there
just for decency and consideration of
other people's property rights as well a
landfill is a pretty significant
structure to be putting up and
um my understanding is that's just there
because I felt it was reasonable to keep
it that far away from the house that had
already been situated
um one last thing and then I will take
questions uh because it was mentioned
before unlike main statute on the first
page line seven you do see five years
instead of six in Maine it is six and as
a one of the previous speakers mentioned
um he didn't feel like five was actually
adequate my understanding why it's five
here instead six is more for political
purposes than anything else
um the the longer the the time that we
allow uh
the less apt we are potentially to um be
willing to hear out the bill so um I
think for political reasons it was
shortened although he may be correct it
may not be adequate
um and I said last thing but one last
thing uh I'd also just listening to the
testimony be curious because I'm sure
people will be coming back up to testify
and they may be able to uh speak to it
it's my understanding that this bill is
site specific in its nature it is taking
into consideration the variables of soil
composition speed flow seepage velocity
and those things would change from site
to site and the setbacks would as well I
mean we have minimum setbacks here that
would have to be adhered to but those
can be adjusted according to the soil
composition of a specific site this
isn't a one-size-fits-all it just gives
minimums that we have to adhere to and
then we can make adjustments from there
so having said that I'd be happy to take
any questions from the committee
so yes I my question initially is you
know I took a look at all these
different uh setbacks minimum setbacks
and and I'm get this is taken from Main
law yes it is so
did they have any technical reasons for
these particular particular setback
numbers or footage or I mean they seem
very arbitrary to me sure um so my
understanding on it um Madam chair is
that uh the last main statute's been in
place since the Late Late 1980s uh they
did a significant review of it around I
believe it was 1999 or so they have done
a great deal of of work themselves the
same kind of work that if we don't base
our model after somebody like me we
would have to do as was stated by the DS
they would bring in experts they would
you know do their measurements and come
up with calculations my understanding
with speaking with people from Maine is
that's what they have done uh to come up
with these setbacks I'm not going to
pretend to understand them thoroughly
myself because that's not my area of
expertise uh I do know that in talking
to them the 300 foot setback from a
roadway or from a property line is what
they came to the conclusion was
necessary to be able to test and
remediate um
before it hits an area that they don't
want to have to dig into somebody else's
property or the road itself thank you
any other questions
uh representative datsey uh thank you
madam chair yeah I think it's a line
um 26 25 and 26 can you just explain
that a minimum 100 foot setback between
the waste handling area I don't know
what a waste handling area would be and
cl and a classified surface water
uh yes representative thank you for the
question um this is actually so as we
all know doing this job sometimes things
are up against a tough timetable uh and
we wanted to get something for the
committee to to give consideration to
actually in Maine statute
um those hundred foot setbacks would
traditionally be a 300 foot setback
um and then through remediation
processes like we've been talking about
you can lower that setback down to 100
feet
um
there are people who can probably speak
better to the specifics of it
um as far as what those things are
technically and I would leave that to
them on either side I'm sure that they
can probably explain that to you better
than I would be able to
okay representative Murray
uh thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question I'm so
the question about
um
the 300 year excuse me 300 foot setback
[Music]
um
is that just
a setback around or oh my understanding
is Maine also has that it can't be over
in aquifer for example uh yeah so that
would be uh thank you for the question
representative that would be if you flip
back to
um line three actually on page two
excuse me the area within the solid
waste boundary shall not lie over or be
within 300 feet of a significant sand or
gravel aquifer
that's where that would come into play
uh which is you know why the 100 foot
setback seems strange further down uh
because technically they should be
looking at those sand and gravel
deposits to see if they're an aquifer or
a significant
source for an aquifer
any other questions representative
Creighton
um thank you madam chair thank you
representative
um so I'm just trying to
push legislation through that makes
sense
well last year we did that we pushed HP
1454 through and and it was vetoed
um very similar legislation to this if
you accounted for the language requiring
additional data and that data driven
solution
um in in creating this bill and if so
how
uh thank you for the question
representative if I understand you
correctly have I considered what data is
driving out
to the governor
I thought I'd do that last year weren't
you listening
um so I mean this is this is a bit
different from last year's legislation
it's also been in place in the state of
Maine for
gosh uh 30 40 years now
um and so I guess a question for the
committee to take into consideration and
maybe ask to some of the other people
who are here who might have more
information on it is do they have a
problem citing landfills in the state of
Maine
um is there any anticipation that and
why would that be that it would be more
difficult to cite in New Hampshire than
it would be to site in Maine if we're
following the same criteria
um
uh once again
unfortunately for the committee that's
you know something that you'll have to
dig into deeper uh but you know that's
that's my general premise is it's been
working in Maine for for decades now
um and is it going to cause some
significant hardship to the state of New
Hampshire to adopt something that seems
to be working for them very well okay
thank you
thank you thank you madam chair and
thank you for taking my question
in listening to the previous testimony
and listening to this
um you're taking main law and applying
it to New Hampshire although New
Hampshire's geography is a lot different
than Maine
so
why would we take another State's
language and put it into New Hampshire
statute when our geography is not the
same
thank you for the question
representative I would say that when it
comes to seepage velocity we're dealing
with an issue from my perspective anyway
we would be dealing with an issue where
we're just trying to give setbacks that
allow us to both recognize when a leak
has happened and then remediate that as
well as prevent it to the greatest
extent possible so whereas our geology
is different the calculations would also
be different but the concept would be
the same
um so we're trying to give ourselves a
significant significant enough amount of
time to recognize a problem and address
that problem so I think from that
perspective working off of somebody
else's model that is working seems to
make sense to me
representative
um Bixby sorry
yes
one uh
one thing that was objected to uh last
to last year's bill was that it did not
uh sufficiently exempt existing
expansions of existing landfills and
that the phrase new is given the way
that it that is used in uh in Des rules
uh actually also applies to any
expansion so
um is that is that something that you
gave any thought to in your drafting
um so that thank you for the question
um that is something that I really heard
for the first time today and happy to
make an amendment for the committee to
make sure that in particular I suppose
Waste Management
um would be an agreement with the bill
um yeah so happy to make that adjustment
thank you representative Murray um thank
you madam chair um thank you for taking
my question as far as the definition I
believe it's online
um
well I don't have lines um but it is
regarding the uh definition of overlying
an unstable area
yes
um
do you have a definition to describe
what is unstable is that a subduction
zone is that a it's sinkhole like what
what what definition is being used to
describe something that's unstable thank
you for the question representative I'm
not 100 sure so that would be something
that the committee would have to look
further into
or perhaps somebody behind me would be
able to answer that better that's
possible as well
any other questions representative Dotsy
thank you madam chair yeah I I just have
to ask this question
um where did why was this bill filed
since there were so many other bills
filed regarding landsville because I'm
not seeing any of the sponsors being
part of the solid waste management or on
this committee so you know where did the
idea for this particular Bill come from
uh thank you for the for the question
and to address the number of co-sponsors
um it was very last minute we had to
rush to get it into OLS and as we all
remember getting things to OLS last
minute was pretty challenging this time
around
um so considering the time frame we had
the number of co-sponsors we got I
thought was was
um fairly good
um
as you just witnessed I would say in the
last hearing a lot of conversation over
the last couple years has centered
around Maine in particular
um what Maine is doing what Maine isn't
doing how does it work why is it
applicable
um so the idea for the legislation just
came
from the idea that if we brought Maine's
legislation forward you could debate
that you could have the discussion over
it and you could decide whether or not
it was fitting for New Hampshire
any other questions
seeing none excuse me thank you for your
introducing this bill
thank you madam chair and I would like
to call Nikki delude Roy
to testify
thank you madam chair and thank you
committee for hearing my testimony and
bumping me a little bit on the schedule
much of my testimony today in the
written version that's going around
repeats comments that I've made
regarding HB 56 so I won't bear
repeating those here today
um
but I do want to say that much of the
language in 602 is similar to House Bill
56 so I'm just going to focus on the
differences and the specific language
that got that seems to be pulled from
the main Regis the main Solid Waste
rules
as proposed HB 602 includes project
Improvement allowances that appear to
have been exerted from portions of the
solid waste rules in Maine
the allowances included in 602 should be
left to the experts at DES to develop in
solid waste regulations in our state
there are obvious problems with exert
excerpting Provisions from one State's
regulations into another State's statute
each state has different local and
Regional geologic settings direct
application of these allowances from one
state to another ignores Regional
differences in geology that would
typically be considered if these
Provisions were left in the hands of the
experts at DES to develop in regulation
the excerpted sections would be included
in New Hampshire statute without the
applicable definitions to the earlier
testimony that are critical for
interpreting and implementing these
allowances correctly requiring that that
Des develop new rules creating
definitions in statute
and leaving them with the untenable
responsibility of trying to interpret
Statute in rule making rather than
developing the rules directly that are
directly and truly protective of human
health and the environment to our state
specifically there are a number of
locations like on line four for example
uh that where a significant sand and
gravel aquifer is referenced without
definition that definition exists in the
solid waste rules in Maine but is not
included here
line 23 again a significant groundwater
aquifer again something that's defined
in main rules but not defined here
lines 25 and 26 A classified surface
water lacking definition here line 28
and 30 preliminary information report is
not something that we use in the state
of New Hampshire but is a defined
document in the state of Maine and to
the earlier comment line 35 an unstable
area is defined in main regulation but
not here in the statute
to add to issues inherent in wholesale
adopting ones state regulations into
another state statute several of the
excerpted provisions cited in hb602 have
actually been modified in a way that
makes them ambiguous or impractical in
the state of New Hampshire
for one as one example
section 4 B3 indicates and I quote the
area within the solid waste boundary
shall be located on soils with
sufficient fines and clay-sized
particles to minimize leachate
infiltration every measurement made of
in-situ soils within the property shall
have an undisturbed hydraulic
conductivity less than or equal to 1
times 10 to the negative 5 centimeters
per second end quote
as indicated in earlier testimony actual
geologic conditions vary wildly and
naturally across the site and the
subsurface heterogeneity is an expected
and natural geologic Factor at all Sites
requiring an entire area and every
measurement to meet a specific Criterion
is arbitrary and technically unjustified
and right and quite frankly
impracticable
for the reasons outlined in my testimony
or urge the committee not to support 602
and to prevent the language from a
proposed in 602 from making its way into
New Hampshire statute but rather to
continue to support DES in evaluating
and updating their Solid Waste
regulations as this is the right
mechanism to provide the protection that
is ultimately sought in this bill as
well as in 56 thank you
thank you for your testimony
um so
previous question to the sponsor of the
bill
excuse me
with regards to Maine's geography is not
the same as New Hampshire's and you kind
of touched upon that
um but the answer to that was that
basically while we have it's the concept
um what's your what's your thoughts on
that is isn't the concept the same well
I guess I would suggest that the best
people to determine that are The
Regulators at DES the experts who we
have at the state to determine what is
applicable from one state to the other
and what is not applicable given this
differences in geology and geography and
topography
so do in your opinion do you think that
because of the difference in the
geologic makeup between the two states
that this bill would exempt a whole lot
more land or include a whole lot more
land than say Maine
I I believe that that's the case and in
particular I believe that that's a very
important
point because the definitions behind a
number of the terms included here are
left out of this of this bill so there
isn't anything to go back to so someone
will have to define those particular
terms and if defined differently than
Maine or in if defined in a way that
isn't applicable to New Hampshire that
certainly could result
thank you any other questions from the
committee representative germana thank
you madam chair and thank you for taking
my question and it's connected I'm sure
to the to the chairwoman's question but
as a scientist and I understand what
you're saying and you've made some very
compelling points about uh terms that
are defined in a statute or rules in
Maine that are in this bill and we don't
have the rules to Define them but I do
want to come back to this question about
for example seepage velocity right so as
a scientist I understand the geological
well I understand that there are
geological differences they won't
pretend to understand what they are but
isn't seepage rate in in some sense a
constant so regardless of of the
geologic makeup seepage velocity would
seem to me to be a constant measure that
would be applicable regardless of what
the geological makeup is
well um so thank you for your question
um seepage velocity really reflects the
geology right and so if in very
simplistic example if I'm at a site and
there's a sand lens and otherwise a clay
environment the seepage velocity within
that that coarser grain material is
going to be higher than in the
neighboring or surrounding clay and silt
units and so it does vary from location
to location and so in that simplistic
example if I were trying to cite a
landfill and the entire site was in
glacial till very low permeability
material there are lenses of sand and
gravel within that material generally
everywhere across the state so you'd be
basically concluding see digital
velocity at that maximum location in
this lens that may be discontinuous and
not really impact the overall seepage
velocity at a particular site when you
look at it as a whole
okay thank you thank you madam chair
representative knabb thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
um can we interpret your support for Des
making these rules to say that you would
support the path presented by the Senate
which would ask Des to address these
rules and look at them or do you think
what is currently I'm sorry we cannot uh
reference the Senate bill at all because
we're talking about this Hospital would
you support a process that that directed
Des to evaluate the current rules around
landfall citing or do you think the
current rules are adequate is that
okay thank you
I would completely support a um process
that would allow Des to consider all the
facts and revise their regulations yes
any other questions
thank you for your testimony this
afternoon appreciate it thank you I'd
like to call now Fred Anderson
Mr Anderson requested four minutes
foreign
thank you madam chair my name is Fred
Anderson
I am a retired Presbyterian minister
and for the last 20 years I've also been
chair of the center of theological
inquiry in Princeton New Jersey
Where We Gather Scholars to take on what
they call life's Wicked questions
we're dealing with one of life's Wicked
questions
for those of you who haven't been here
for four years this is the fourth year
in a row I've had the pleasure of
talking with you about the issue of
landfill citing but today I don't want
to talk to you about the technicalities
I don't want to talk to you about the
science
I want to talk to you about something
else
I'm sure you'll hear all the
technicalities and I've heard all the
arguments already
I'm aware that many of you if not most
of you are people of Faith you would
call yourself a person of faith I don't
know where that would be Christian
Muslim Jewish whatever but someone who
has a sense of accountability to God
after all when you took your oath of
office you said so help me God did you
not now if in fact you have a problem
with swearing in God's name you said
under what
let me quote it
I do this under pains and penalty of
perjury was that the phrase thank you
consequently what I want to talk to you
about
I want you to consider this bill or
actually these two bills I chose to
speak only this evening at this point
I want you to think about it from the
perspective of faith
and ethics
the Book of Genesis tells us that in the
beginning God created the heavens and
the Earth and that everything in them
was good
and God gave this gift of creation to us
and it had in it everything that is
needed for life but God gave it to us as
God's stewards
now it turns out this gift is
extraordinarily fruitful
it's not simply brimming with life it is
alive itself
those of you who are farmers know this
already
I have here in my hands a book by Dr
David Greenspan one of the members at
CTI who was part of our initial study
into the ramifications of finding other
life in The Exodus Dr Greenspan Dr
greenspoon is a member at CTI he is a
planetary scientist and now an
astrobiologist and he's written this
book Earth in human hands shaping our
planet's future
Dr Greenspun makes the point that Earth
is the only planet in our solar system
that is alive
we alone have a biosphere to bring forth
nurture and sustain life and in this
book he talks about the consequences
of life on Earth because of the
decisions we human beings have been
making and the story is not heartening
Mr Anderson we need to be talking about
this bill I am please I'm talking about
the criteria that you use by which you
decide
what the environment is about that will
enable us to continue to live we are
looking to see whether there are aspects
of this bill that are uh
favorable or not and so I would like to
keep to the the body of the bill and and
with all due respect I've talked and
I've talked to you about the body of the
bill for three years
with all due respect I'd like to talk to
you about how you're going to approach
making these decisions
as people who are ethical as people who
are concerned about life on this planet
as people who are concerned about those
who may come after us please keep your
comments to the topic of the legislation
and whether or not it should be passed
or not okay first of all I'm absolutely
convinced that either one of the bills
could be passed and secondly probably
you may well want to combine the two of
them to find to answer some of the small
technological questions you've had but
it's very clear
that if we don't do something to stop
what's going on in New Hampshire we're
destroying ourselves
and we will destroy the Earth and that's
what Dr greenspoon is saying so he's
saying we have a chance and the Chance
is for adopting bills like this is it
the full solution absolutely not it's
simply lighting one candle rather than
cursing the darkness so what I urge you
to do is to vote ought to pass if you
want to merge the two bills gladly merge
them make them even better you folks
have the capacity to do that
and then pass it and then let's do
everything we can to see that the Senate
agrees and thereafter let's see if this
time our governor will take what the
people of this state need seriously
thank you madam chair thank you Mr
Anderson any questions
from the committee
thank you for your time thank you and I
would like to Now call Dr Adam Finkel
and you've requested three minutes
thank you all right
breathe easier excuse me thank you again
for a chance to come back I'll be brief
I hope uh maybe like sentence at a time
little sound bites uh
first I would just urge you if you have
either one minute or four minutes to
take a look I sent you all uh two links
to YouTubes a a Charming 13 year old
middle school student last year put
together a video uh that I also cut to
one minute just to show
it nothing substitutes for seeing it in
real time how different good soil and
good Bedrock is from sand and gravel and
those uh
funnels full of colored water the ones
with the clay underneath it were sitting
there for a whole week before we started
that demonstration and not a drop
fell into the beaker below the sand and
gravel we did in real time and within a
few seconds all the liquid had
percolated through and again the beauty
of that experiment is it's six out of
seven funnels have Clay because six out
of seven randomly chose in sites in New
Hampshire will be acceptable
hydrogeologically for a new landfill
uh secondly
I I frankly I've heard some unscientific
things here today the questions we're
trying to get uh the the errors
corrected and they didn't didn't work uh
if you drop a tennis ball here in this
room it will fall to the ground in a
certain amount of time and if you I
guarantee if you go across the border to
Maine gravity works the same way so
the my understanding is that the amount
of acceptable land in Maine and New
Hampshire May differ slightly but the as
you said representative germano the
concept is the same it doesn't change
anywhere on Earth you can measure
velocity and you can apply it to change
velocity to time
and so the fact that Maine may have
slightly different ramifications that
that may be more or less of their land
would be uh made unsuitable for
landfilling by by their law and regs
what we know is in New Hampshire the
vast majority of sites would still be
applicable under either of these bills
uh the question of Statute versus
regulation so I don't want to go into a
long history here so I was the chief
scientist at the federal occupational
safety and health administration in the
Clinton Administration and the Bush
Administration I wrote rules I wrote the
federal respirator Rule and a number of
others but we also on occasion were
directed by Congress to
implement verbatim rules that Congress
wrote for us there were times for each I
believe this is a time for statute
because of the difficulties the Des has
and look frankly I don't really
understand what Des is supporting or not
supporting today at one point it was we
need more discretion we don't like being
micromanaged at another point we don't
like the table of offsets because it
gives us too much discretion this is a
time for the legislature to speak with
broad Strokes of policy now I don't
profess to have been here at the time
but I think whoever was here did a great
thing I don't know 20 years ago it's
called Jessica's law not Jessica's
rulemaking right you guys decided your
predecessors that that piles of snow on
the roof of a car were a bad idea and
somebody got killed and I'm I'm sure
somebody were getting a lot of static up
and Dalton you're being reactive to uh
to a problem well yeah all good
legislation is reactive we have a real
problem somebody trying to dig bury 18
million tons of trash in a sand pit next
to a lake and so we're asking for a
reaction just like Jessica's parents
asked for a reaction but you didn't have
a study you didn't send it to rule
making you made policy and that's what
we're hoping you will do uh in this case
I think just one or two more quick
things the distinction between using the
maximum measured value and some average
I said earlier today
frankly the problem with the average is
it's easily manipulable by moneyed
interests who want to manipulate the
game
so I agree that there are value
judgments to be made here whether we
want to use the maximum value or the
average value but let's not pretend one
is unscientific and one is not they're
both science policy judgments and it's a
feature of these two bills that they
require
the applicant to sample as little or as
much as they want but they're Bound by
the highest value they get because
that's a real number for somebody to say
well it might just be a lens that only
goes in One Direction that's a real
number and it says the the leachate will
Flow Away from the site at a high rate
of speed through that formation
maybe it's
tilted towards Environmental Protection
more than tilted towards profit but of
course I think that's a good value
judgment so let's not be fooled by this
random utterances of unscientific nature
the the both these bills are science
based the only real difference between
them if you're really kind of puzzled
about the the numbers in the language I
think I can make it real simple the main
or the bill 602 is more stringent in one
one important respect it follows the
main uh concept that you should if you
go to a site as a developer you dig your
first test well you find you're in a
sand pit pack up and go away there's no
variance there's no uh allowance for
that no matter how far away the water is
Maine says why on Earth would you dig in
a sand pit
56 doesn't quite say it that way it says
if you're five years away in a sand pit
we're okay with that so I prefer
56 because I think it's more of a
balance between protecting the water and
not digging in the wrong place but I see
the real Merit in a in a more uh
protective more easily understandable
prohibition which is what is in 602.
um
and I think that's it the only other
really interesting point is about last
year's veto uh you know are either these
bills sufficiently different to escape
another veto and all I will say is at
some point I hope the governor listens
to some of the industry that is saying
enough is enough we need a better system
and I think it's quite appropriate to
try one more time uh a bill that is
Laden with uh I won't call them
concessions they are valuable uh
balances to what industry itself asked
for
thank you sir any questions
seeing none oh representative Bixby go
ahead
one of the objections that was raised to
uh 602 and I I I must confess I'm a
little bit uh sympathetic to this is the
lack of definitions do you think that's
a flaw that would need to be fixed
yeah I think it could be fixed pretty
easily my understanding is that uh
a lot of the definitions in the in the
main system are just cross-reference to
main statutes which would not be
objectionable if they were simply
repeated verbatim as as you know as a
definition section I don't think the
definitions in Maine are in any way uh
unreasonable or bizarre it's just they
are terms of art like like sensitive
receptors they have their own name for
that and we ought to either figure out
whether we have exactly the same term of
art or need to sort of paste it back in
as a reminder
thank you
representative germana thank you madam
chair uh and I that representative
bixby's question reminded me of the the
map the much disputed map that we've
discussed and it says that the sources
was New Hampshire Des but adapted from
U.S uh GS and so I'm wondering in terms
of definitions is is there some overlap
also through USGS in terms of of
defining some of these geological
characteristics you were talking about
kind of what Mains are based on but is
there also a larger body through USGS
for example that contains definitions as
well oh USGS is is using words like uh
clay or they're using words like glacial
till whereas main is using a very very
precise number 100
000 centimeters per second which is
about 10 feet per year uh so yeah I
prefer the main system but the map is
just to show you know in a in a easily
understandable graphical form that
within a lot of uh approximation and a
little bit of play
86 percent of the state is prima facie
probably a decent place to put a
landfill it's only to say that all of
this sky is falling talk about we're
never going to be able to put another
landfill if you split really hard you'll
see that little yellow Square on that
map in the legend that is all the land
we need for the rest of the century to
bury our trash if we can't find a little
yellow Square in that vast green area
something's wrong with us we don't need
to go into the worst possible locations
to look for landfilling may I follow up
Madam chair follow up thank you uh and
my question really was about so are you
familiar with where those main as you
said they're much more specific they're
much more precise in terms of how they
Define clay Etc uh do you know were
those developed by geologists in Maine
or or do you know where they got that
data I've talked to the the counterparts
in in Maine uh uh who do the same job
that uh Mr Wimsatt does and what they've
told me is they picked 100 000
centimeters per year because it was
again 10 10 feet per second I'm sorry 10
feet per year they wanted about a
hundred years
for uh in all cases for the the leachate
to Traverse uh a a long enough distance
that they were comfortable
you in other words even though I had a
six-year thing in their in their legs
they were really thinking about a
hundred years as the kind of lead time
that we really would would like to have
so while they have variances and they
have offsets and ways to get closer than
100 years they were really looking at
let's just not set ourselves up for
trouble by digging in what is
essentially sand and gravel but they're
putting a number on it they're putting
on that 10 to the minus fifth
centimeters per second to to to mimic
Sand and Gravel thank you and thank you
madam chair
representative Howard
um and to me it seems I I a question
about uh The veto again
um a lot of the the prohibitions have to
do with human interaction with the the
site right the near roads near property
boundaries do you think that that will
make it less passable
um or or harder make it harder to get it
past the governor
well yeah I think you're probably I mean
I think it will take a little more
education uh for uh the sponsors or the
the proponents to explain why there is
why there are so many different sub
paragraphs talking about residences and
uh and and other as as representative
Simon said human decency uh issues here
but I would hope that those wouldn't be
controversial that if somebody would
take the time to listen that sort of
again
with all due respect you know 44 pages
of operation maintenance closure ranks
are great but the but the one and a half
pages of citing criteria in our state
are not nearly enough so it looks like a
lot of verbiage but it's because it's
being overlaid over really
threadbare system right now
any other questions
see none thank you for your testimony
this afternoon
I'd like to Now call uh director Mike
wimsat
and I guess Mike's Mark Sanborn as well
hello again
good afternoon Madam chair thank you
again
um for the record my name is Mike
Wimsatt a service director of the waste
management division for the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services and with me is our assistant
commissioner of the department Mark
Sanborn
um as a lot has been said here about the
the similarities between this bill and
House Bill 56 and and there are indeed
some similarities and I won't I won't
repeat my testimony relative to those
similarities but I would note that a
very significant difference with this
bill or a couple of them but but one is
that it uh looks to set a a five-year
travel time distance for not just
surface waters but for this category of
sensitive receptors and sensitive
receptors is is quite broadly defined in
the in the bill to include certain
aquifers Water Supplies sand and gravel
deposits which are not defined in
perennial surface and then of course
perennial surface waters
so that that means it has a
significantly greater impact in terms of
what what different features need to be
have a have a setback determined for
them
I guess what I would say is that with
respect to the undefined nature of this
broad the broad definition of sensitive
receptors but the but the terms within
that being undefined it creates some
some difficulties one is that if Santa
gravel deposits isn't defined and that
depending on how you define that that
can describe much of the of the
overburdened soils in New Hampshire
um and certainly at sites where there
may well be other soils that are much
less permeable and might meet the
criteria in the bill but there are sand
and gravel deposits often closely
associated with those very same slow
flowing soils and the the issue uh I
think it's been it's been addressed a
little bit but I will repeat it the the
idea that all soils at a site need to
meet the 10 to the minus 5 centimeter
per second criteria that's not something
that's terribly common the way that the
bill and the words matter here it's easy
to say well we just mean we want the
sites to be in places where water
doesn't move that fast but the reality
is that there may be sites where water
doesn't move very fast but those sites
will also have soils that have
permeabilities that are much greater
than 10 to the minus 5 centimeters per
second so if you say all the soils at
the property need to meet that criteria
it's really unrealistic and and probably
that combined with these other terms not
being adequately defined results in a
situation where virtually no site could
be could be could be deemed acceptable
for a landfill sighting and I I'm not an
expert on how Maine applies their laws I
don't know the definitions of these
terms in the main rules I think much of
this is contained in rural in Maine
rather than in law but the words really
matter here and before we could embark
on changing the statute in a way that
that uses these rules in my view in a
way that is careless is we could end up
with the result that we none of us
really anticipates
and I I think I'll just leave it at that
and entertain any questions unless Mark
wants that yeah I'll just really quickly
following the chair's guidance of course
just say this bill does not outline the
approach we would be recommending or
supporting to address this policy issue
uh representative Creighton
uh thank you madam chair thank you again
for your your testimony and
uh so you heard the previous testimony
it said that uh
that basically This was
[Music]
um
a good way to go about doing this your
testimony says it's not a good way about
going there so how would you advise us
in terms of
squaring that
conflict there
well I I think that you know as as we've
stated earlier
um
it's clear to us you know we've been
here before this committee for a number
of years now with a number of bills
there's a lot of concern about
how the current rules address or in some
views don't some people say don't
address citing criteria adequately and
so we believe that that certainly time
has come where we're going to need to
look at these citing criteria and and
Shore them up in some fashion that's
going to be acceptable to the general
court and to the regulated community and
to the public and that's a delicate
balance but I think that you know the
other bills that have been referenced uh
by myself and by assistant commissioner
Sanborn
provide a good outline of the criteria
that we should be looking at and give
some clear guidance on how to use those
criteria to develop citing more specific
citing criteria particularly with
respect to surface water setbacks and I
think that I think we think that that
can work but we're here today to talk to
you about these two bills and and I
think you've heard from our testimony
that we think that they are in many
respects fraught with pitfalls that make
them unsuitable
and I'll just quickly add uh sticking to
this bill
um
oh yeah
we our goal is to have a coordinated
effort to really
look at these issues from
utilizing and the reason we're utilizing
a we've thought about using a third
party is because our staff if they all
they had to do was this they could get
together and and and do this work we
just simply our staff similarly doesn't
have the time to dedicate to doing the
research and background and data
collection needed to give our our staff
the right tools to come up with a
rulemaking so that's why
um and the approach we've talked about I
I I think the key here is we're we're
not disagreeing or agreeing with
anyone's testimony what we're saying is
we would like a coordinated effort done
in a process driven way that gives us
all the information and all the data and
and analyzes our neighboring states so
we aren't relying on just the testimony
with all due respect of individuals you
know here in this room offering their
perspective and we want to have a more
coordinated holistic approach to looking
at this and coming up with the right
answer for the State of New Hampshire
not disregarding what other states are
doing but looking at all of it in a full
way and finding out what makes the most
sense balancing all the needs of the
state the environmental the natural
resources the economic
across the board and so those are the
measures of what will be supporting and
we think is the best path to moving
forward
thank you very much
any other questions
representative Knapp
thank you madam chair I just wonder what
you think the timeline of that would be
because we're hearing that we don't need
a landfill for a long time we're also
hearing that there's a landfill concern
in the state I apologize that I'm new to
this process but um you know it I I
recognize the points you make about
about getting the best rulemaking policy
in place but what is the time frame of
doing that when asked this questioned by
others we have said we think two years
um would be enough time to go through
the RFP process to select to allow
a firm a selected Consultants to do
their work to analyze that work and then
do the uh the regulatory rulemaking that
would be required there would be overlap
in that some would feed off each other
um so it's if they're not completely
isolated activities there's some overlap
but
um what we've stated is we think two
years is while aggressive I do time
frame for us to go through that process
representative Howard
the 602 has been effective and working
well for 30 years in Maine doesn't that
sort of give you a jump start on the
process and and that's I have one a
second question to follow up on that and
that is that if we were to pass this
bill could it be a guideline for you
setting rules around the details that
that you feel May differ
I I guess um
if the bill were to pass it's more than
a guideline it's the law and we would
have to
incorporate and admin and develop and
adopt rules that were completely aligned
with the law and that's that's the
problem the guidelines we can but that's
not what what these bills are these are
these become law
representative Bixby
yes thank you for taking my question if
uh we were to amend this in some way as
to make it a pro a a process to a
development process for rulemaking
um as you suggested you're interested in
would do you feel that would make sense
to have a moratorium on any new
permitting of landfills until that
process was completed
so
um just the director's always in a tough
position because uh Mike being directly
involved with approval has to be very
careful about speaking especially that
specific so I'll take care of that
answer
um uh we our policy position is we are
going to be neutral on the concept of a
moratorium we'll respect what
um the lawmakers and ultimately if the
governor agrees comes up with on that
um I I will say this I I think
um I think
any of these legislation could be
crafted in a way where
um we would be able to do the work we
need to do
um and and that time would would allow
for
um uh any future sites to to uh be be
regulated
um and just one note though because you
talk about amending I do want to be
transparent and clear
the starting point for this
um this legislation has written is
pretty far away from the approach we're
taking the the key to the approach we're
supporting is no prescription of what
the rules should look like before and
passed in statute but allowing but
giving us the tools and the time frame
to to bring forward rules that we think
are based on
um data and
um other examples
um you know and and that's how we would
develop our rulemaking I you know I've
heard the term use the main is working
well that's a subjective term it and
what are you balancing what policy
impacts are you balancing are you saying
just the environmental are you saying
the economic impact or you know the the
cost to the residents depending on what
availability so we I can't sit here and
tell you any of these things are or
aren't working well what I can tell you
is if if we're given the chance to to
work with a third party and find out
that information we will only do a
better job coming up with rulemaking
that makes sense for the State of New
Hampshire
representative Murray
Madam chair and thank you for taking
[Music]
sources to do some of this stuff
adequately
to the best of your ability and I guess
so the follow-up question I have on that
is how long would you say it has been
since you have adequately had enough
resources to do this work
well well
interesting conversation at budget time
uh but um at least when I was referring
to resources that wasn't an advocacy of
we need more Personnel that that's not
the point I'm making the point I'm
making
um in order to do this the right way it
would require staff to completely focus
on this and not be able to focus on
their existing regulatory
responsibilities so I I did this what
we're seeking to do is is is is to
gather information gather data and do
some analysis on it and it's a very
intense time-intensive project and
um and and that's why we we talked about
the idea of this is a great example of
where government can look for outside
help to do a very specific time-driven
task
um focused on that well we continue to
do our work provide the information and
then we can incorporate it in rules that
we think will end up where we all want
to be balancing all our policy impacts
that we're trying to balance natural
resources environment economic quality
of life
costs to our residents
representative datsey
yes thank you madam chair so
um I need clarification so if if this
goes forward and you are able to hire a
third party okay is legislation going to
come out of that that we would then vote
on or are you saying that the end result
of this third party is rulemaking and
the legislature would basically be cut
off oh I want to be careful of the
chairs rule about how we talk so I'll
talk about it more generically than
specifically uh generically speaking the
approach would be
directing us to do a study with
guidelines and directing us to then use
that study for rulemaking with some
guidelines so it would lead us to the
whole process would lead us to do rule
making based on guidelines that are in
the statute
representative Dotsy just to clarify
there would be no legislation coming
forward for the process that you're
talking about no there there are there
are ways to approach legislation that
would
um direct us to conduct the study with
some funding and then um rule making
with some broad guidelines of the areas
of the rule making we would want that
the state would want us to be addressing
and then uh we would then over about a
two-year period
um conduct those activities
um and have the data we need and the
background we need to do uh bring
forward or rule making that as Des staff
we feel would we feel comfortable
represents all the interests of the
state representative
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
on the same topic uh just listening to
things and I just want to for a point of
clarification it is my understanding
that what we pulled here in 602 from
Maine is not actually in statute but in
their rules is that correct
I don't pretend to be an expert on that
I'll hand it over to the director I
don't have a definitive answer on that
it's my understanding there may be
components that occur in both places but
I believe much of what is in this occurs
in rule in Maine
representative Haskins
thank you
and gentlemen so we have a conundrum we
have scientists who make
um a good case for both sides
and
you have a different responsibility than
we have
but in the back of my mind
are the people who are waiting for the
lawmakers to help them with a problem
that cannot wait
and I live on the Seacoast so I have
some experience of a 20-year fight with
regulators
um so I I guess I just
I wonder if we can both appreciate this
conundrum
we have different responsibilities
and with respect at the end of the day
we meet we discuss and we come to a
consensus
um
and we will do that with ethical
considerations as well as our
particular scientific knowledge however
meager it may be but I um
I just want you to appreciate that
um we recognize expert testimony is what
we need to make these decisions but when
it conflicts we do our best to sort it
out and make a good decision does that
make sense yeah let me yeah let me
answer this way
um
we too want to see something passed and
have Direction
um
and
without being overly specific I'll I'll
tell you this much
during the break between the last
session and this session we talked to a
lot of folks about something that could
have the support of the legislative both
Chambers and
um you know the governor's office so
um
we are recommending both what we feel is
the best approach for Des
and our role and
um based on what we think is going to be
powerful enough to enough folks that we
could actually move forward with
something and not just continue to
debate because to your point
um uh
folks coming forward with their
prescripted idea hasn't resulted in any
actual movement on this issue over years
now so the time that would result from
the process where
um we're suggesting is still less time
than it would take if nothing passes and
there are more years of fight
legislatively representative Murray
thank you madam chair and with all due
respect I just
would like to just make the point I
guess with regard to representative
Haskins statement that we do have a very
specific charge within this committee
and part of that is dealing with air and
water pollution waste management and
other other issues that come before us
so to that end I do think we have an
obligation to get it right and we've had
a multitude of
people coming from many different
perspectives here before us seeking an
answer
So to that end I I would hope that we
have the opportunity to sit
and work those through in a way that
would
arrive at an answer that may be more
amenable we will always work with all of
the state's elected officials and and
the general court
um as you speak of your role all I can
tell you is I can only be here in viral
and in the in our role
um within Des as the folks being asked
to implement whatever is passed what
we're bringing forward is what we
believe is in the best interest of the
state and in the best interest of what
we feel would lead to the best result
um as the folks at the es who are going
to be implementing it and we feel there
is we need more information more data
and a more process different driven
approach to this versus one-off
individual recommendations
that are from folks passionate folks I'm
not judging them either way on their
intellect their
experiences their engineering scientific
knowledge I'm I'm saying uh usually in
in government when you use a process it
is better than using one-off testimony
to make a decision and
um so all I can do as assistant
Commissioner of of Des is bring forward
what we think is in the best interest
from the perspective of the department
thank you uh representative but we will
always work with the the general court
and of course whatever the general court
ends up passing and if it's signed into
law by the governor we would of course
follow whatever on the state's due the
elected officials direct us to do thank
you representative German I had a
question yes thank you madam chair uh I
want to get at something that's at least
been a subtext here which is the
difference between statute and Rule and
the the different roles of Statute
versus versus a rule and you'd made a
comment a few minutes ago about what you
would like to see or a set of guidelines
which allow you to make rules that you
believe balance say environmental
interests economic interests of the
state but my question to you is isn't it
our job to decide what that balance is
between the the environmental and
economic interests of the state as
literally as as Representatives uh so
here he's saying and the reason why I
raised that question again is to
highlight why perhaps something should
be in statute as opposed to develop as a
rule because if it if it involves those
questions aren't those questions
precisely the ones that should be
decided by elected representatives and
then rules based upon the decisions that
that are then made I'll answer that this
way if the legislature feels they have
the right answer and the right approach
to this issue and pass that in statute
and the governor signs that we'll follow
that of course yes you are the 424
members of the general court a governor
and we have those five executive
counselors that every two weeks approve
our contract so uh the 430 folks are
certainly
um the the folks who directly are
directly sent by the people and and are
the policy makers of the state
um what I was referring to is
we
if asked what we feel
is in the best approach what we feel we
can do given the tools we have what
we're saying is we think more
information is needed in a defined
process will result in a better that's
our recommendation of what we think
would turn out the best result but what
you are if you all feel comfortable and
enough folks in both in both Chambers
feel that way and the governor agrees
that'll be the answer of course
thank you very much thank you madam
chair representative Howard
table legislation for two years and wait
for you to come back to us with the with
the results of this consultant process
again I'll answer this generically
legislation could be done so that it
agains it outlines what's in the study
and then it outlines the parameters of
what should be included in rule making
and directing us and we would move
forward with rulemaking and the
legislature still has the ability if
they don't like what we come up with
um to pass legislation directing us
um to change those rules as the
legislature sees fit so there's still
plenty of opportunity for the states
elected officials to to weigh in at that
point
um if if there's consensus
something in how we went about it wasn't
wasn't done the right way and needs to
be changed
any other questions
seeing none thank you very much and I'd
like to call Cynthia wall thank you
members of the committee yep like to
call Cynthia Walter
and you've asked for three minutes
thank you for hearing me again today
um I it was wonderful to hear all of
this discussion all day long and
I am speaking now as somebody who has
worked with the uh folks similar to the
Des we call them in Pennsylvania the dep
for uh over 20 years
and working with those uh of folks and
also other Professional Engineers
I have a chance to see firsthand
the importance of clear guidelines four
regulations that came from statute down
to regulations through a messy process I
agree but then we're enacted I've also
had the chance to see how engineers in
trying to do the right thing would make
terrific mistakes and I see that coming
through
um in ways of correcting
mistakes that can easily happen
in House Bill 602
so I see the strength of the Simplicity
of 56. I see the strength of the details
in 602
and I appreciate the humility of the Des
to say
flat out what I heard today is they do
not yet know how to safely cite
landfills
in New Hampshire
and they need two years to figure it out
I also heard them say that they need
just like the dep folks that I worked
with they need principles and guidelines
from you that are important what do I
see in 602 and 56 and perhaps other
things I see that there's a need for a
100 Year protective framework
whether you get it from the one you know
the velocity of this and that whether
you get it from an assessment of soils
however you get it
100 Year protective
the attention to sensitive receptors
cannot be underestimated it has to be in
a revision of either 56 602 whatever no
new number you give it
it needs to be there and here's why
New Hampshire as you heard one of the
other testimonies today
we have an abundance of running fresh
water surface waters we also have an
abundance of important groundwater
supplies for public water for public
drinking water
that combination in the United States
that combination in the world
is extraordinary
running surface water is the rarest of
the rare Waters in the world and you
have in a New Hampshire has an abundance
of that you must protect those rare
surface waters you have an abundance of
drinkable groundwater
that is I mean I've been in continents
around the world and it is so rare to
have drinkable groundwater folks I just
just amazing so you have to collect
everything in between and therefore that
100 year and the sensitive receptors has
to be in the new guidelines and then
there's the Practical setbacks
I can't tell you how many times we have
had Engineers who said no we can do this
and there we're standing in 500 gallons
a minute discharges flooding ourselves
up to our waists my hip my hip waders
were not sufficient
we never know what is going to happen to
discharges of contaminated water and
where they'll end up this one with these
300 foot and and 1 000 foot setbacks
between this property and that property
it allows you to do what we oftentimes
couldn't do in Pennsylvania is put in a
remediation really fast to get to handle
that 500 gallons a minute
unexpected discharge that the engineers
said wouldn't be there but they were
humble just like the the Des is humble
so I strongly encourage you
to take the people who sponsored 56 and
602 craft
a legislation that gives the Des
the money and the time two years to
create
a new set of laws with the statute that
you design that says those things that
we can have to keep and save the baby
and the bath water no pun intended
thank you any questions
thank you for your excuse me thank you
for your testimony oh I'm sorry
um representative Murray and
representative Haskins can you shut your
microphone off thank you
I did just have one clarifying Point
were you asking for the date to be
enacted two years from the time of the
legislation being crapped I just want to
be clear about what you were no no what
I meant was well I don't I'm just gonna
give them
what they estimated was two years so
again I can't I'm not good at rewriting
laws I'm only good at you know doing
data so
I'm not sure how you
how you would craft the statute that
says
these the guidelines for developing
rules that will provide 100
that have that will have rules that will
have a 100 Year protective framework
that would have this and that and that
you put a time limit on it so they're
not going to drift forever in developing
those rules because it's true there's
nobody knocking on our door right now in
terms of landfill citing but that
doesn't mean that somebody won't be
arriving soon for some reason
that's what I meant she just suggestion
put some limit on it that's all
thank you any other questions
thank you
it's okay
uh I'd like to Now call uh
representative David Rochford
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee uh my name is David Rochford
I'm from Littleton representing Grafton
one with representative Simon I'd
prepared some remarks but I think it's
late and we've heard a lot of this stuff
over and over again I'm going to kind of
dispose with that for everyone's sake
what I was going to talk about is is uh
money and resources and tourism and and
all the wonderful things that bring
people to New Hampshire but I wanted to
address a couple things I think Dr
representative ducci asked uh how about
some of the co-sponsors and I'm
co-sponsoring 602 and quite frankly I
would be happy to co-sponsor 56 as well
we our family bought a house on a lake
uh in 2017 and it was an old house as a
camp
um and we what we didn't know we were
buying was an environmental time bomb
we bought a house that was about 100
years old and about the time the house
was built all the land around this house
was farmland
sheep farming and cattle farming and
going back about a hundred years ago
even when it was deforested but that's a
whole other story
um you know there was there was unknown
what what
chronic fertilization uh animal waste
things like that would do but what
happened fast forward to 2017 and what
we know now is there's something called
gravity everything flows downhill and
our case was not landfill related it was
cyanobacteria related and I'm I'm I'm
gonna get off topic a little bit but I
promise I'll get back on topic if you'll
entertain me
um
and what we realized or what we we found
out was that little bit of phosphorus
that flowed downhill was just enough to
tip the the the Eco system of the lake
to a situation that caused a bacteria
Bloom so when representative Simon asked
me if I want to sign on to this he knew
about our situation the lake is in
Littleton uh it's Partridge Lake I said
absolutely because we need to if we can
take
action now to prevent something in the
future
we will protect everyone's property and
property rights who are Downstream
now I'm not going to be able to answer
any questions about science I am a
Scientist by by profession I'm not an
engineer uh I'm not a hydrologist I
don't even really know what that is
probably studying water or a geologist
I'm a pharmacist
in my profession
100 years ago
we use leeches and lobotomies
to treat headaches PMS
postpartum depression aches and pains
and infections
and we realize that there's a better way
to treat people
and there's a better way to to to take
care of people
and I'm convinced that whether we go
with 56 602 a combination there's a
better way to do what we're doing than
the way we're doing it now
so I hope that answers your question how
I got onto this I'm not I'm not an
environmental background guy
um
quite frankly I probably should be
better at recycling but but uh I I I've
experienced the ramifications of things
that happened decades ago
so
looking at these these these bills they
use modern accepted techniques they've
been around for other states we're not
reinvented we're not inventing the wheel
with that this is not an anti-business
Bill if it was you'd I'd be the last one
to sign on to this
um you know it's a it it's actually in
my opinion a pro development bill in
that it it encourages smart development
and sustainable development it's not
anti-landfill like I said we all have to
throw stuff away
it's just making sure the stuff that we
throw away today doesn't come back and
hurt us 50 years down the road that's
happened to our family so again I
thank you for listening to me
um I I do hope something comes of this
it is an important issue uh and I
appreciate your time thank you thank you
for your testimony any questions
seeing none thank you thank you and I
would like to Now call Tom Tower and
you've requested three minutes to speak
and I know that it's been
a very long day
and it's obviously a very passionate
subject so I'd like to take just a
minute and I'll go off script as well to
speak about the history
so that people have perspective there's
a lot of new faces here on on this
committee and the conundrum that you
spoke about
uh so for the record my name is is Tom
Tower
and I serve as the vice president of
North Country Alliance for balance
change
I'd first like to thank representative
Simon and representative rocherford
representative Moody representative
wrong
for submitting 602
and for being champions for clean water
and uh in the great state of New
Hampshire
um
we're not going to debate any more about
this 200-foot setback even Des
recommends that something needs to be
done so that goes without saying
but this 602 so the history behind 602
was
and again a lot of people have
reiterated that we've been doing this
for four years now right so we we hear a
lot of back and forth we want to try to
accommodate as many people as possible
and so many people so many legislators
said well we we need something more main
like you know why can't we do it like
Maine
right because Maine
has gone through a pain staking uh
painstaking technical studies they had
public hearing and it's been in place
for 20 or 25 years now the assistant
Deputy uh or the Deputy Commissioner
spoke about well that that's conjecture
but it's been in place for 20 to 25
years haven't seen a lot of things
necessarily in the news talking about
you know landfill and contamination in
Wayne in Maine and that kind of thing so
it's obviously doing something right
we talk about whether or not now is a
good time well now is a perfect time
there isn't any active permits for
landfills in the state we could
speculate all we want but there isn't
any active permit and people talk about
2034 in capacity well I'd like to say
that that 2034 is probably an
underestimate because within the last
couple of years or within the last year
I should say the solid waste working
group actually updated the solid waste
plan and one one of the things that they
outlined in that plan was a 25 reduction
in solid waste output in the state of
New Hampshire by 2030. now I realize
that that's a lofty goal but at the same
time even if the state only does half of
that that 2034 timeline gets extended a
lot further a lot further so the point
of the matter is here we have the time
to put something in place to make the
right decision for the public health and
safety and for the business other people
in the state of New Hampshire
House Bill 602 House Bill 56 they don't
need they're not asking for money you
know they're not asking to appropriate
hundreds of thousands of dollars to do
studies why because they're pretty good
when we look at at what is House Bill 56
the previous version and this one has
been amended because we saw a
representative from Waste Management
basically say well last year we're
really concerned that you couldn't
expand existing landfills and that would
be a big problem there was too much
ambiguity well Waste Management says I
think you've taken the ambiguity out so
this is a better bill
this is a better Bill what was the
primary reason that the governor vetoed
last year and believe me we took a
painstaking look at why the governor
vetoed this bill and what did he say he
said because we're concerned we can't
expand any existing landfills in the
state and we've got to really be in a
problem
so what do we do we we basically said we
should update and amend what is 56 now
which is an improvement over 1454.
there was only one bill
in the state of New Hampshire one
that was overridden in the House of
Representatives and that was House Bill
1454. why because it had cross-section
bipartisan support unlike any bill
that basically that was vetoed by the
governor no other bill was vetoed but
this one why because it was a good bill
and then it actually passed the house
coming in and then ultimately The veto
wasn't sustained so what do we do we
tried to improve
so from a conundrum perspective we'd
like to say look 56 and and 602 both
are good bills
to speak about what's going on in
another chamber and I applaud Madam
chair
it really doesn't have
any business and what's going on here in
the house committee
what's going on over there is conjecture
and I appreciate Des saying well there
may be some other things
to be honest with you
these are good bills
these can be put in place without a lot
of of cost now granted Des may have to
go through some some energy and and
resources to put these into practice if
they become law
so what we're saying is let's take a
look at what is in front of you I'd
recommend past them both
give give choices to the Senate
let the Senate decide what's good and
what's not and we could have a very dare
I say robust conversation about this as
this continues
so
that's all I have to say and I am happy
and I know this has been a long day and
you all deserve credit for sitting
through this but I'm happy to take any
questions you may have
thank you any questions
representative NAB thank you very much
it's a quick one but since you
referenced them in your letter do you
know anything about Vermont and
Massachusetts standards
uh thank you for the question
representative
I cannot speak to the standards but what
I can say
is that Vermont in Massachusetts
are not permitting any new landfills in
their state any longer
one of the reasons why
New Hampshire has a little bit of a
challenge in that the existing capacity
in New Hampshire quite frankly people
uh is certainly ample for many many
years to come the elephant in the room
of course is out of state waste
any other questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you madam chair thank
you committee I really appreciate your
efforts today thank you and I would now
like to call
um
Mr tothill from Acworth
you've requested one minute
thank you madam chair John Tut Hill from
Acworth and Sullivan County one minute
I've been a few snowflakes already so
keep it short
um
it's been a very interesting afternoon
and your patience has been extraordinary
I agree with Mr tower that both bills
should be passed I'm very glad that
these are in the house these are policy
committees this is important policy it's
critically important at this time to
protect New Hampshire going forward we
don't have two years the time for the
Des to be
proactively studying and researching how
to improve citing regulations was some
years ago I was around on the Seacoast
in the 70s and 80s when Coakley was
operating grew up over there
that followed it sense was there when it
closed
there was discussion today about
remediation Coakley still has not been
remediated millions and millions of
dollars have been spent
um
after Des was formed in 86 and I should
point out the first commissioner came
from the waste industry
rules were soon being written for the
air division the waste Division I was at
some of those meetings and Industry
basically dominated the rulemaking they
had the resources they had the time and
they had the interest and those are the
rules that we're living with today in
terms of citing so in 2023
with the changes that we've seen in in
the marketplace for resource management
and waste management I think we really
need to just
stop and and get hold of what frankly is
really quite a dangerous situation for
the state because people have talked
about things flowing downhill a waste
flows downhill as well and we are at the
bottom of the hill thanks very much
thank you any questions uh
representative Murray uh thank you madam
chair
um thank you for taking my question and
this might be
uh maybe even more to Des but if my
memory serves me correct Coakley
landfill is a designated Superfund Site
is that correct correct
thank you
any other questions
thank you for speaking with us
I have uh Eric steinhauser
foreign
like to please request that if anything
has already been spoken of that we can
skip it thank you madam chairman I was
going to start with that statement I'm
passing around my written testimony I
wouldn't need to read one part
um there's a disclaimer but for the
record my name is Eric steinhauser I
made my introduction before
um I do need to say that
um I am a member of the New Hampshire
Waste Management Council representing
licensed engineers and I represent the
Council on the new New Hampshire uh
solways working group my testimony today
is mine and does not represent opinions
or thoughts of the waste management
Council or the Southwest working group
I will not repeat what I said earlier
um or some of the testimony that's
already been made and I will keep my
comments to the legislation components
first I just want to reiterate the
difference between a statute and a rule
um
the statute is is you know
to use the the pastor's uh comment is is
Gospel we have to follow that a rule if
there's an issue with the rule we can
negotiate
um how to apply that rule based on the
actual site that would not happen with
the statute
so the preference would be to have
things in rules not not prescriptive in
a statute I do encourage the committee
there's a lot to learn about landfills
and we've heard some testimony that
really has applied to unlined and old
landfills not the new modern landfills
that are built designed built in and
operated under the rules that Des has
personally I'm not aware of any
remediation being applied at any of the
new line landfills in the state
um and I also want to uh just talk about
a comment that was made about the
maximum value that a applicant can go in
a
reduce the average number by getting a
lot of data I would also challenge that
theory is that you can challenge the the
value because she didn't find the
highest value like you didn't study
enough to find the one location that had
the highest value that could ever be on
that site so our high geologist friends
are doing their best to characterize the
site Based on data but just to use a one
value and not consider the whole site
holistically is a
I think a scientific issue it also
presents problems for engineers as we're
trying to use
um the whole site as as a
for our work
um
the other thing I wanted to mention is
is there is a discussion about the map
it came up a couple times that had the
stratified drift in a potentially yellow
spot on the map where we could put all
our waste forever which not included in
that map there's all the other citing
criteria in our current rules
um that by topography and by other
issues would really limit where we could
put landfills so
um I agree with a study process Des is
going through their rule making they
have to renew their sideways rules now
that's in the process could they be made
stronger and better for for both sides
of the aisle I think so
um but just to be prescriptive and just
pick values whether they're arbitrarily
selected or not or how you view that I
think the study process is a more
appropriate procedure
with that I'll take any questions thank
you thank you any questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you thank you for your
testimony this afternoon I do not have
any more pink cards does anybody else
wish to speak
on HP 602 today
okay seeing none
I would Now call this oh I need the blue
sheet
blue sheet
and online we had
um for 602
285 people in favor of this legislation
and two in opposition
and on the blue sheet
we had
one two three four five six seven eight
nine in favor and one against
thank you very much I'm gonna close uh
the hearing for hb602
and next week
on um February 28th
we will have a full committee work
session or we're planning to have a full
committee work session on these three
bills that we heard today
um plus one other hp221
and then in the afternoon we will be
executing a plethora of bills
so
um
that's all I'd like to say about this
committee I want to thank everybody for
their time and attention it's been a
long day
and I really appreciate the work that
everybody is doing on this committee and
hopefully we will be in conversation
about
um where we're going to be going with uh
with what we've heard today
so thank you